5, 2, 1, Start.
4, 3, 2, 1, Start. Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 126. Mein Name, ihr seid es gewohnt, Tim Pritlove und heute bin ich mal wieder auf Reisen gegangen, eine kleinere Podcast-Tour, die mich heute nach Darmstadt geführt hat. Darmstadt kommt ja immer wieder vor hier, das liegt daran, dass in Darmstadt so viele kluge Leute arbeiten. Das hat aber immer wieder einen anderen Hintergrund. Und heute bin ich in einen Hochsicherheitsbereich hereingelassen worden, Gott sei Dank. Und zwar musste ich hier meine Personalien aufgeben, um Besucher zu werden des ESOC, des European Space Operations Center, sozusagen hier der lokalen Niederlassung der ESA, European Space Agency. Und ihr ahnt es schon, das Thema heute verlässt ein wenig den Boden, auf dem ich mich normalerweise bewege und wir heben ab. Es soll hier im weiteren Sinne um die Raumfahrt gehen. Und wo sollte man da sonst auch anders hingehen? Und ich bin sehr froh, hier einen kompetenten Gesprächspartner begrüßen zu dürfen. Ich begrüße Rainer, Rainer Kresken, hallo.
Hallo.
Und du arbeitest hier bei der ESA in Darmstadt. Wie ist das so?
Wie ist das so? Ja, ich mache hier eigentlich Ingenieursarbeit. Ich arbeite an astronomischen Forschungs-Satelliten. Ich steuere die mit einem Kollegen zusammen. Wir kümmern uns darum, dass die Satelliten ordentlich funktionieren, dass die zur richtigen Zeit an den richtigen Ort schauen, das beobachten, was die Astronomen gerne sehen möchten. Damit versuchen wir, hier die Wissenschaft zu fördern und die Satelliten entsprechend ihrer Zielsetzung einzusetzen.
Also Space Operation Center heißt ja, hier wird vor allem gesteuert und kontrolliert. Also hier geht es wirklich ganz konkret darum, die fliegenden Objekte in der Luft, naja nicht in der Luft, im Raum zu halten. Wird hier auch gebaut? Wird hier auch zusammengezimmert?
Nee, überhaupt nicht. Das ESAG, das European Space Operation Center, ist eine Einrichtung der European Space Agency, der ESA. Und wir konzentrieren uns hier tatsächlich auf den Betrieb von Satelliten. Es gibt andere Zentren der ESA, zum Beispiel das Zentrum Estec in Nordwijk in Holland. Da kümmert man sich um den Bau und die Entwicklung von Satelliten. Und andere Zentren, zum Beispiel Esrin in Italien, kümmert sich um die Datenauswertung im Wesentlichen. Und wir haben auch ein Zentrum in Madrid, die kümmert sich um Aspekte der Astronomie im Weltraum. Aber wir hier sind für den Betrieb und für die Steuerung von Satelliten zuständig. Wir arbeiten mit diesen ganzen Zentren zusammen, aber unsere Aktivität ist ziemlich klar abgestellt. Wir kümmern uns um Satelliten, die im All sind und steuern die.
Also meine ESA ist ja klar, europäisch ist man auf eine ganze Menge Zusammenarbeit angewiesen. Das ist ja auch generell so in der Raumfahrt, weil die Dinge ja dann immer die ganzen Planeten umkreisen. Und da hat man ja auch viel zu tun mit den anderen Agencies der NASA, nehme ich an, was es sonst noch alles so gibt.
Ja, wir arbeiten mit den nationalen europäischen Raumfahrtagenturen zusammen. Die sind auch ziemlich rege und haben auch eigene Projekte. Aber die arbeiten auch konkret mit uns zusammen. Da gibt es immer wieder Berührungspunkte. Und die anderen Einrichtungen der ESA arbeiten mit uns zusammen. Und es gibt ständig irgendwelche Berührungspunkte. Wir haben natürlich auch Industriepartner in ganz Europa, die für uns die Satelliten bauen. Und die sind hier oft da und kümmern sich auch mit uns um den aktuellen Betrieb.
Das heißt, ich bin ja hier das erste Mal hier, muss ich sagen, und eben gerade noch so ein bisschen vor dem Gespräch ein bisschen durch die Gegend gelaufen und durch die Räumlichkeiten, sobald man sie betreten darf. Da gibt es dann vor allem viele Kontrollzentren, größere Räume, wie man sich das so vorstellt, mit vielen Bildschirmen, wo dann so ein paar Leute davor sitzen und die ganze Zeit auf Zahlenkolonnen blicken. Das ist ja hier sozusagen das tägliche Brot. Jede Mission hat hier so seinen eigenen Raum und beobachtet im Prinzip die laufende Mission.
Ja, das ist richtig. Aber was man da sieht, also die Arbeit in den Kontrollzentren, in den Kontrollräumen, ist eigentlich nur die Spitze des Eisberges. Also hier gibt es etliche Büros und viele stille Büroarbeitsplätze. Und da wird der Betrieb vorbereitet. Das heißt, dass wir da Software schreiben, die man braucht, um die Satelliten zu steuern, Software, die man braucht, um die Daten, die vom Satelliten zu kommen, interpretieren zu können. Da werden viele Dokumente geschrieben, so Benutzungs-, Bedienungsanleitungen und Prozeduren. Und das ist eigentlich der Hauptteil der Arbeit, die wir machen. Das, was man da in den Kontrollräumen sieht, das ist die sichtbare Spitze des Eisberges.
Aber es konzentriert sich schon auch auf die Steuerung dieser Satelliten. Also im Wesentlichen ist sozusagen die handwerkliche Tätigkeit, die Dinger überhaupt im Raum zu halten und quasi im Betrieb zu halten. Es geht hier nicht so sehr um die eigentliche wissenschaftliche Auswertung der gesammelten Daten, oder ist das hier auch ein Thema?
Nee, das wird hier überhaupt gar nicht gemacht. Also die wissenschaftlichen Daten werden eigentlich sofort weitergereicht an die Wissenschaftler, die die brauchen. Wir haben damit nichts zu tun.
Und die sind auch nicht hier auf dem Gelände?
Die sind hier in der Regel nicht auf dem Gelände, nee. Nur gelingt, ich schau mal welche rein, um sich hier vor Ort da ein bisschen mit den gewissen Begebenheiten vertraut zu machen, um eine technische Einweisung zu kriegen. Aber eigentlich werden die einfach durchgereicht. Also wir haben eine kleine Ausnahme hier. Wir haben eine kleine Ausnahme vom Betrieb von Satelliten. Wir haben hier die sogenannte Missionsanalyse. Und die wird eigentlich sehr, sehr früh in der Planung einer Mission aktiv. Die legen fest, was ein bestimmter Satellit können muss und welche Bedingungen erfüllen muss. Das schreiben, das machen die ganz früh in der Mission. Dann sehen wir von der Mission erst mal lange nichts. Dann wird die gebaut und die Planung, die da in der Missionsanalyse gemacht wurde, ist in Hardware umgesetzt. Und dann, wenn der Satellit existiert und wenn alles definiert ist, dann kümmern wir uns um die Vorbereitung des Betriebes. Und dann sind die Aktivitäten wieder her. Aber das ist die einzige Ausnahme, diese Missionsanalyse als Anrat, nur wirklich noch mit dem direkten Betrieb von Satelliten zu tun.
Das heißt, hier geht es wirklich auch um die Raumfahrt als solche, also um die technische Durchführung. Hier hat man es wirklich konkret mit der Physik. Und es gibt so einen schönen Begriff Flugdynamik.
Wie nennt ihr das? Ja, das ist das, was ich in meiner Gruppe mache und das, was ich mit meinen Kollegen zusammen mache. Flugdynamik hat zwei Aspekte. Erstmal die Steuerung des Fluges in der Umlaufbahn. Da muss man wissen, in welcher Umlaufbahn sich der Satellit befindet. Dazu haben wir Messanrichtungen. Wir kontaktieren den Satellit mit Antennen. Und aus verschiedenen Obachtungen können wir entschließen, wie schnell sich der Satellit bewegt, wo er gerade ist und wie weit er weg ist. Das wird dann mathematisch analysiert und daraus wissen die Kollegen dann, wie die Umlaufbahn genau aussieht. Und der andere Aspekt ist die Lage-Steuerung. Der kümmert sich halt darum, die Ausrichtung eines Satelliten im Raum zu steuern. Beim astronomischen Forschungssatelliten heißt das konkret, wir richten das Teleskop des Satelliten auf ein Objekt aus, das die Astronomen gerne beobachten möchten.
Da können wir gleich noch mal ein bisschen drauf kommen. Ich wollte jetzt erstmal noch mal so ein bisschen in die Geschichte blicken. Die Geschichte der Raumfahrt kommt jetzt schon einiges zusammen, aber so richtig alt ist diese Disziplin ja nicht. Ich weiß nicht, was müsste man denn sozusagen als das Ureer-Ereignis der Raumfahrt benennen? Was ist denn so der Moment, wo man sagen kann, so jetzt hat die Raumfahrt begonnen?
Das erste, was ich als Raumfahrt bezeichnen würde, sind die Flüge der V2-Rakete, die das deutsche Militär im Zweiten Weltkrieg unternommen hat. Das war das erste Mal, dass man von Raumfahrt sprechen kann. Die haben eine Rakete entwickelt, die, wie sie heute auch gebaut werden, die haben die technischen Probleme erkannt und die haben da ziemlich geniale Lösungen gefunden.
Was waren denn die technischen Probleme?
Zunächst mal ist die Steuerung einer weltraumtauglichen Rakete ziemlich problematisch.
Wo fängt der Weltraum eigentlich an? Was ist die Definition? Ist das diese 100-Kilometer-Grenze?
Ich glaube, die Definition sagt 100 Kilometer, aber das ist vollkommen beliebig eigentlich. Aber wenn man in diese Höhen ab 100 Kilometer vordringen möchte, dann kann man ein Gefährt nicht mehr so steuern wie ein Flugzeug, weil da viel zu wenig Luft ist und irgendwelche Steuerung anhand der Luft zu unternehmen. Alles, was darüber hinausgeht, würde ich als Raumfahrt bezeichnen, denn da muss man einen Flugkörper so steuern wie eine Rakete mal.
Das heißt, man verliert die Aerodynamik und hat es mit anderen Kräften zu tun?
Genau, ja. Und jeder weiß, wie ein Flugzeug aussieht. Ein Flugzeug hat einen Leitwerk hinten. Das Leitwerk sorgt dafür, dass die Spitze immer vorne ist, möchte ich mal sagen. Und das funktioniert ab einer gewissen Höhe einfach nicht mehr, weil die Luft viel zu dünn ist. Und da würde sich ein Flugzeug in dieser Höhe so ausrichten, wie es gerne möchte.
Und dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie umkippen.
Genau, oder irgendwie anfangen zu taumeln. Und dann müsste man anfangen, zum Beispiel mit kleinen Steuerdüsen dafür zu sorgen, dass die Spitze vorne ist. Und solche Sachen, die wurden zum ersten Mal eigentlich von den Schöpfern der V2-Rakete technisch gelöst.
Das war ja eigentlich schon eine sehr theoretische Arbeit, weil in den Höhen konnte man ja in dem Sinne nicht operieren. Man wusste ja wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal um die konkrete Beschaffenheit der Luft. Also war bekannt, wo die Atmosphäre endet?
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Die haben das mehr so über den Daumen gepeilt, würde ich sagen. Die sind da ziemlich hemmsärmlich erst mal rangegangen. Wernher von Braun war ein genialer Ingenieur, das muss man so sagen. Der hat die Probleme richtig erkannt, die technischen Probleme und hat die Lösung.
Was waren denn seine Lösungen? Also was steckt denn nun drin in dieser V2-Rakete, dass sie Dinge tun konnte, die man vorher nicht machen konnte?
Zum Beispiel braucht man ein Regelungssystem, also ein System, das durch Sensoren feststellt, wie die Rakete ausgerichtet ist und dann braucht man einen Regelmechanismus, der das entsprechend korrigiert, wenn die Lage nicht so ist, wie man sie gerne haben möchte.
Was für Sensoren sind das?
Kreisel sind das. Das hat Werner von Braunheim zum ersten Mal wirklich technisch umgesetzt. Der hat also Kreisel benutzt, um Rakete zu steuern. Das hat der Herr Gold hat in den USA auch gemacht. Die beiden sind, würde ich so als gleichrangig bezeichnen, was messen die Kreisel? Die Kreisel können ihre eigene Ausrichtung im Raum feststellen. Also wenn man einen Kreisel andreht, dann hat er das Bedürfnis, diese Ausrichtung erstmal beizubehalten, wenn keine äußeren Kräfte und Momente auf ihn wirken. Und diese Eigenschaft kann man ausnutzen, um tatsächlich einen...
Also das, was man so kennt, so einen kleinen Tischkreisel, wie die Kinder ihn benutzen. Man dreht den, dann ist er irgendwie senkrecht. Und wenn man so ein bisschen gegenstupst, dann will er wieder zurück.
Genau.
Aber wie ist denn dann dieser Kreisel, muss man sich das jetzt wirklich vorstellen, wie so ein Kinderkreisel, der dann irgendwie in dieser Rakete irgendwo drin war? Was hat der dann gesteuert? Gab es da Elektronik in dem Sinne? Gab es ja nichts?
Doch, es gab... Also das ist gerade das, was... was von Brauns und Zentrinen da richtig gelöst haben. Also sie haben erst mal erkannt, wie man so einen Kreisel einbauen muss. Nämlich man muss den Kreisel in so eine entsprechende frei bewegliche Aufhängung montieren. Die ist ermöglicht, dass sich der Körper drum rum, in dem Fall die Rakete frei bewegt und dass man dann die Ausrichtung des Kreisels, der seine Lage beibehalten möchte, da relativ zur Rakete messen kann. Und aus diesen Signalen, die man auf dem Kreisel gewinnen kann, muss man dann entsprechend...
Wie wurde denn dieser Kreisel gemessen? Also ich sehe das jetzt so, die Rakete fliegt, irgendwie der Kreisel dreht sich. Wodurch dreht sich dieser Kreisel? Also der wird angetrieben, oder was ist das?
Ich glaube, die haben da Elektromotoren.
Da hat er die schon verbaut. Das heißt, das Ding dreht sich, dann macht die Rakete irgendwie einen Mux nach oben und dann will der Kreisel sozusagen diese Bewegung ausgleichen.
Der Kreisel lässt man... Man kann es so machen, dass man den Kreisel im Raum fest ausgerichtet lässt und die Rakete dreht sich dann drum herum. Das ist möglich wegen dieser kandanischen Aufhängung.
Und wie misst man das dann?
Da hat man dann so Winkelgeber in den Rahmen eingebaut. Und da hat man tatsächlich so Analogcomputer gebaut, die dann aus diesen Eingangssignalen dann Ausgangssignale für die Steuerung der Schubdüse produziert haben. Ausgesprochen trickreich für die damalige Zeit.
Und das hat dann was gesteuert? Was ändert sich dann, wenn diese Bewegung festgekriegt wird?
Wenn da irgendwie eine Ausrichtung oder eine Verdrehung des Kreisels gemessen wurde, wurden Ruder bewegt, die in den Raketenstrahl reingereicht haben. Die hat man aus Grafittmaterial gebaut. Die waren halt so gebaut, dass sie die enorme Hitze des Raketenstrahls aushalten konnten. Und die haben dann in den Raketenstrahl eingetaucht, den Raketenstrahl ausgelenkt und dadurch auch Drehmomente auf die Rakete wieder rumproduziert, die versucht haben, die Rakete wieder aufzurichten.
Aber jetzt muss ja die Lenkung, ist ja nicht konstant, wenn das Ding irgendwie startet, dann soll es irgendwo ankommen, muss ja irgendwie über die Laufzeit des Fluges quasi eine Art Programm geben.
Genau, richtig. Ja, sowas haben sie auch entwickelt. Die haben also die Rakete auch programmiert, nämlich man muss da eine bestimmte Richtung einhalten, eine bestimmte Kippgeschwindigkeit, damit die Rakete sich in die richtige Richtung auch dann neigt, wo sie hinfliegen muss.
Das war eine erhebliche Berechnung schon.
Allerdings, ja. Das war eine geniale Leistung. Dann kam noch...
Da haben dann damals wirklich so richtig Mathematiker gesessen und gerechnet. Tabellen, nehme ich mal an.
Ja, also das war ein sehr interessanter Mix von Leuten. Also da waren viele Ingenieure bei Mathematiker und alles sehr kreative Leute, die eigentlich einen Raumfahrt betreiben wollten.
Und natürlich auch noch ein bisschen Kriegsgeschäft nebenbei als Hauptziel.
Ja, aber das ist, würde ich gar nicht mal so sagen, wenn man mal was am Beispiel Wernher von Braun wirklich festmacht, der war in meinen Augen kein überzeugter Nazi und er hatte auch nicht viel Interesse an dem Krieg an sich, aber der wollte Raumfahrt machen und das Militär hat ihm damals die Möglichkeit geboten, da Raumfahrt zu betreiben. Er hat sich da vollkommen über den Tisch ziehen lassen und er hatte auch nicht rechts und links geguckt, bei dem, was er gemacht hat.
Die typische Scheuklappenproblematik der Nerds und Techniker.
Ich betrachte das nicht als Entschuldigung für das, was er gemacht hat und er hat ja auch billig in Kauf genommen, dass in den Penemön und in den Raketenfabriken auch KZ-TET-Eftlinge eingesetzt wurden. Das hat ihn eigentlich nicht interessiert. Er wollte Raumfahrt machen und hat dabei alles andere vollkommen ignoriert. Viele von seinen Kollegen waren auch so gestrickt, würde ich sagen. Das waren begeisterte Ingenieure und auch Leute, die den dringenden Antrieb hatten, eine Raumfahrt zu machen. Die wollten eigentlich zum Mond und nicht irgendwelche Raketen auf Mos auf London abschießen, aber die haben das vollkommen billig in den Kauf genommen. Also bei Wernher von Braun auf jeden Fall, ja. Unmöglich. Also der hat als kleiner Junge schon Raketen gebaut und beinahe seine Nachbarschaft da abgefackelt, aber der wusste genau, was er wollte. Der wollte zum Mond. Er hat eigentlich als Erster die technische Realisierbarkeit des Mondflugs erkannt und sich auch fest vorgenommen, das umzusetzen. Und er hatte auch wirklich die Fähigkeit, das zu machen.
Du sagst, er hat die Realisierbarkeit erkannt, nachdem er diese V2 gebaut hatte sozusagen?
Vorher schon.
Es war ihm vorher schon bewusst.
Ja, also er hat das Glück gehabt, aus seiner Sicht, dass er an wegweisende Literatur gekommen ist, die Rakete zu den Planeten räumen, von Hermann Obert auf jeden Fall. Das hat er gelesen und dieser Hermann Obert war auch ein Visionär.
Was war das in Science Fiction?
Das war überhaupt kein Science Fiction-Buch. Das war ein technisches Buch, in dem so theoretisch dargelegt wird, dass man mit Raketen ins All und zum Mond kommen kann.
Das war aber erst mal eine Vermutung sozusagen, oder eine These, die nicht zu belegen, die erst mal zu belegt werden müsste.
Das war ein Buch voll mit Formeln. Das habe ich auch zu Hause. Das ist ein sehr, sehr eindrucksvolles Buch. Also Hermann Obert hat so die theoretische Möglichkeit dargelegt. Also er hat gesagt, so um eine Rakete zum Mond zu bauen oder ins Orbe zu bringen, muss man so und so schnell fliegen und wenn man eine Rakete baut, die diese und diese mathematischen Bedingungen erfüllt, dann geht das.
Wie hoch ist denn diese V2 dann tatsächlich geflogen?
Die ist deutlich über 100 Kilometer hoch geflogen.
Deutlich über 100?
Ja.
Also jetzt so testweise oder auch, als sie dann zum Einsatz kam?
Ja, auch als sie zum Einsatz kam.
Und war das auch, das war sozusagen notwendig, um diese Distanzen zu überbrücken?
Ja, die musste also so hoch und so weit fliegen, um ihren Zweck als Kriegswaffe da zu erfüllen.
Und gut, ich weiß nicht, wie weit kam diese Entwicklung dann noch innerhalb des Krieges? Also die V2 kam ja dann zum Einsatz, ist auch irgendwie über England niedergeregnet. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie noch irgendwo anders...
Ja, die wurde im Wesentlichen auf London abgeschossen, aber auch auf andere Ziele in gründlichen Teilen Europas zum Beispiel. Und Werpen hat eine ganze Reihe von Fahrzeilen mitgekriegt.
War das für den, ja schon eine zynische Frage, aber war das sozusagen für den Kriegsprozess eine relevante, also hatte das eine entscheidende Kraft oder war das eher so eine technische Leistung, die aber sozusagen im Krieg eigentlich keine wirklichen Ergebnisse erzählt hat?
Nee, im Gegenteil. Also wenn man das wirklich mal so nüchtern militärisch betrachtet, hat es den Deutschen sicherlich mehr geschadet als genutzt. Also die Entwicklung der V2 war sehr, sehr aufwendig, hat irrsinnige Ressourcen verbraucht und hat wenig, was man so als militärischen Gewinn bezeichnen könnte, gebracht. Also von daher war die ganze V2-Entwicklung sicherlich ein Verlustgeschäft, wenn man mal so in diesen Wertmaßstätten wird.
Jaja, klar. Aber heute ist es natürlich Standard. So, dann war der Krieg vorbei, Wernher von Braun ist dann in die USA, ja, ich weiß nicht, geleitet worden, freiwillig gegangen.
Unmöglich, er ist freiwillig gegangen. Er war ein kühler Rechner, er wusste, dass die Amerikaner um den militärischen Nutzen der Rakete wissen und er hat sich denen wirklich angebiedert.
Weil er halt weitermachen wollte.
Er wollte weitermachen und er wusste, dass die Amerikaner erstmal Interesse an seiner Arbeit hatten, dass die Amerikaner sicherlich auch seine Leistungen zu schätzen wissen und dass die Amerikaner die Ressourcen haben, um das erfolgreich weiterzuführen.
Was gab es denn außer Wernher von Braun und ich nehme an, so eine größere Gruppe von Leuten um ihn herum, noch andere Forscher und Gruppen, die in irgendeiner Form da schon Fortschritte gemacht haben, unabhängig von denen in diesem Bereich? Oder war das wirklich die eigentliche Keimzelle, wo das erste Mal an Raketen gearbeitet wurde und sonst hat das erstmal keinen interessiert?
Nee, da gibt es noch einen, nämlich Koroljow in Russland. Der war ein Ingenieur, der sicherlich nicht weniger begabt und fähig war als Wernher von Braun, aber der hatte halt lange Zeit nicht die Ressourcen, die Wernher von Braun hatte. Also das russische Militär hat sich nicht für Raketen interessiert im Zweiten Weltkrieg und von daher konnte Koroljow in keiner Weise da auf irgendwelche Ressourcen zurückgreifen, die die technische Entwicklung ermöglicht hätten. Im Gegenteil, Koroljow war noch in den Zeiten des Zweiten Weltkriegs in Sibirien im Gulag eingesperrt und war da KZ-Häftling. Er ist erst nach dem Krieg, als die russische Regierung von ihm gehört hatte, da wieder rausgekommen.
Von ihm gehört hat, dass er solche Entwicklungen macht.
Genau, ja.
Das heißt, die sowjetische Raumfahrtentwicklung ist eigentlich vollkommen unabhängig gewesen von der Deutschen und später dann auch von der Amerikanischen, die sich unabhängig voneinander entwickelt.
Kann man so sagen. Koroljow hat nach dem Krieg auch einige V2s bekommen, die vom russischen Militär in Deutschland eingesammelt worden sind. Der hatte auch ein bisschen rumgearbeitet. Der hatte auch ehemalige deutsche Mitarbeiter da in seinem Team. Und da gab es auch ein paar Testschüsse, aber der hat schnell die Finger von gelassen, weil er zu Recht erkannt hat, dass die V2 eine Sackgasse darstellt. Die hat zwar funktioniert, aber das Konzept der V2 hatte ganz klare Grenzen.
Was war denn falsch? Also was waren die Grenzen der V2?
Die war zu schwer und war nicht wirklich geeignet, um eine mehrstufige Rakete daraus zu bauen. Die V2-Bahn hat eine einstufige Rakete und da gibt es ganz klare Leistungsgrenzen, die unzureichend sind, wenn man wirklich in die Erdumlaufbahn möchte. Um in die Erdumlaufbahn zu kommen, braucht man eine mehrstufige Rakete. Und Korn Roljow hat schnell erkannt, dass es in dieser Hinsicht nicht weitergeht mit der V2. Der hat sich das also angeguckt, hat ein paar Testschüsse gemacht, hat von den Antriebskonzepten gelernt, aber dann seine eigene Kiste praktisch von null auf aufgebaut.
Und Wernher von Braun ist dann auch auf dieses Mehrstufenprinzip gleichgegangen? Oder sind die dann erstmal eine Weile noch in dem Bereich?
Die haben noch ein bisschen weiter gemacht mit der V2-Technik, haben da auch einige Aspekte weiter benutzt, aber dann auch ganz neue Raketentypen auch entwickelt, ohne das Wissen da zu vernachlässigen, was man da aus der V2 geholt hat.
Ja, so nach dem Krieg, 50er-Jahr, dann brach ja auch sozusagen ein totales Feuer aus für Raumfahrt. Kann man das so sagen? Oder kam das eigentlich erst später? Das kam definitiv erst später.
Nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg kam dann gleich der Kalte Krieg und die Atomrüstung. Das Einzige, was man an Raketen spannend fand, war die Möglichkeit, mit Raketen Atombomben zu transportieren.
Es gab generell so eine Begeisterung für diese Moderne, die Technik und so, aber es manifestierte sich komischerweise immer noch in diesem Atompilz aufzufahren und so weiter.
Ja, und genauso war es auch bei Koroljow. Seine Aufgabe war, leistungsfähige Raketen zu bauen, die Atomsprengköpfe nach Amerika transportieren konnten. Aber er hat dann auch, er war ja auch im Grunde gestrickt wie Werner von Braun, er wollte auch Raumfahrt betreiben und er hat dann nachher eigentlich den Khrushchow belabert, dass er auch mal einen Satelliten hochschießen darf, mit der Rakete, die eigentlich als Atomwaffenträger gedacht war.
Das war aber irgendwie, das war irgendwie so ein Hack, also er hat irgendwie die Ressourcen, ist er dann derjenige, der den Sputnik losgeschossen hat?
Genau, er hat die Trägerrakete für den Sputnik gebaut und auch den Satelliten selber entwickelt.
Aber der Satellit als Seucher war überhaupt gar kein Konzept, was die Russen jetzt konkret verfolgt haben, oder?
Nee, das war eine Ratz-Fatz-Entwicklung, da wurde in ein paar Wochen wirklich zusammen genagelt und war einfach nur eine Kugel mit einem Funksender drin, der hat Piep-Piep gemacht und das war's.
Ein paar Beinchen dran.
Genau, ja, das waren diese Beinchen, die man da sieht, das sind halt Antennen gewesen, die halt zur Verbreitung des Piep-Piep gedacht waren.
Und ich erinnere mich, ich habe irgendwann mal so eine Geschichte gehört, darum, wie sich das so entwickelt hat, aber dass es irgendwie überhaupt gar nicht so richtig im Mittelpunkt stand, jetzt wirklich einen Satelliten hochzuschießen, dass er aber irgendwie alle Leute so beschwarzt oder getäuscht hat, um ihm die Ressourcen und die Genehmigung dafür zu erteilen, das dann irgendwie zu machen. Und als das Ding dann auf einmal oben war, waren sie alle ganz überrascht.
Ja, da ging es dann los. Da hat jedermann erkannt, was das für eine Wirkung hat. Und man hat sich da auch Gedanken gemacht, wie man da weiter machen kann. Aber zunächst mal war wirklich die Prestige-Wirkung dieses Satelliten da. Also die ganze Welt war sehr zu Recht schwer beeindruckt von dieser technischen Leistung. Und das war auch eine sichtbare technische Leistung, denn man konnte tatsächlich die Rakete am Himmel fliegen sehen, auch von USA. Man konnte nicht den Satelliten selber, aber die Oberstufe der Rakete über den USA fliegen sehen. Und das hat die Leute dort mächtig beeindruckt. Und die ganze Welt hat das schwer beeindruckt.
Was war denn das denn jetzt für eine Raketentechnik, die die dann zusammengeschraubt haben, um dem Sputnik ins All zu kriegen? War das jetzt schon so eine mehrstufige Rakete?
Das war eine mehrstufige Rakete.
Und warum braucht man mehrere Stufen?
Weil man ein bestimmtes Verhältnis von Leermasse und Nutzmasse haben möchte. Ich stelle dir vor, du hast eine riesen Rakete, eine einstufige. Dann wird die Leere unnütze Masse immer größer, je mehr Treibstoff da rausgeblasen ist. Du fliegst dann noch einen leeren Tank durch die Gegend zum Schluss. Um das zu vermeiden, wird halt der leere Tank so weit wie möglich abgeworfen, indem man halt Leere unterstufen.
Also es geht einfach darum, Ballast zu verlieren und leichter zu werden, umso weiter man nach oben kommt.
Aber man möchte halt vermeiden, tote Masse hochschießen zu müssen. Wenn man eine große Rakete hat, dann fliegt man zum Schluss nur noch einen leeren Tank durch die Gegend, mit ein bisschen Sprit unten drin.
Aber umso höher die Rakete ist, umso weniger Kräfte müssen da überwunden werden.
Das ist richtig, aber das macht eigentlich relativ wenig aus. Man muss zunächst mal die Lufttreibung verwenden, das ist erheblich. Die Erdanziehungskraft wird geringer, je höher man kommt. Aber der Effekt ist ziemlich schwach. Was wirklich wichtig ist, ist, dass man so wenig wie möglich tote Masse durch die Gegend fliegt.
Was ist das, was man im Wesentlichen erst mal überwinden muss? Ist das die Luft, das Haupthemmnis nach oben zu kommen?
Das ist ein erhebliches Hindernis. Und das andere Hindernis ist die erhebliche Beschleunigung, die man dem Satelliten mitgeben muss.
Und warum muss man den so beschleunigen?
Weil man eine bestimmte Geschwindigkeit braucht, um in der Erdumlaufbahn, in der Umlaufbahn zu bleiben.
Was ist das für eine Geschwindigkeit?
Das hängt von der Umlaufbahn ab. Sobald man ab 7,5 Kilometer pro Sekunde geht es los, darf man mitspielen.
Und umso höher die Umlaufbahn ist, umso schneller muss das Ding sein?
Je höher die Zielumlaufbahn ist, umso schneller muss der Satellit beschleunigt werden beim Start. Also wenn man die Erde ganz verlassen möchte, wenn man wirklich aus dem Einfluss der Erde ganz rausfliegen möchte, dann muss man die Rakete auf etwa 11 Kilometer pro Sekunde beschleunigen.
11 Kilometer, damit die Rakete als solche überhaupt erst mal rauskommt. Aber dann geht es sozusagen darum, wenn man einen Satelliten hat, dass man den dann absitze, der übernimmt dann sozusagen diese Geschwindigkeit und schießt dann um die Erde herum.
Genau, ja.
Und diese Mindestgeschwindigkeit muss quasi in Relation stehen zu dem Abstand, damit die Geschwindigkeit als solche quasi, dass die Fliehkraft so stark ist, dass sie sich der Erdanziehung entgegensetzen kann.
Genau, ja. Ja, genau so ist das.
Wenn wir keine Atmosphäre hätten, wie viel von der Energie würde wegfallen, wenn man so eine aktuelle Ariane 5-Rakete nimmt, das ist ja ein ganz schöner Trumpf, wenn man sich jetzt einfach mal nur die Luft weglässt? Wie viel kleiner könnte man das Ding dann bauen?
Kann ich dir so stehenlich sagen.
Also wäre das so die Großteil oder so ein bisschen was? Also ist man im Wesentlichen eigentlich damit beschäftigt, die Erdanziehung zu überwinden oder ist man im Wesentlichen beschäftigt, die Luft zu verdrängen?
Das finde ich ja schön, dass ich dir eine Frage stellen kann, man. Man sollte sich ein Drittel des Raketenaufwandes sparen, wenn man die Atmosphäre nicht hätte.
Ein Drittel?
Ja, würde ich mal so über den Daumen fallen, aber das ist vollkommen ohne Gewehr.
Okay, aber das ist in Größenordnung. Also macht was aus, aber ist auch nicht die ganze Geschichte.
Genau.
Wie viele Stufen hat man dann so üblicherweise?
Es ist unterschiedlich, die größte Rakete, die bisher erfolgreich geflogen hat, da war die Saturn V Rakete, die hatte drei Stufen.
Drei? Und so eine Ariane V?
Die hat eine Hauptstufe, die ein eigenes Triebwerk hat, die große Tanks hat. Da, rechts und links, sind Feststoffbooster befestigt, die verarbeiten so wie Feuerwerksraketen. Die werden angezündet und dann geht es los und die werden erst wieder auf, wenn sie leergebrannt sind. Und darauf ist dann noch auf diesem Packen aus drei Stufen sozusagen noch eine weitere Stufe drauf gesetzt.
Das heißt, so richtig Stufen im eigentlichen Sinne, diese Ringe, wie man das immer so kennt aus diesen hübschen Bildern, gibt es jetzt gar nicht mehr so eine einfache Antwort. Es gibt mehrere Elemente, die so für sich brennen und einzelne Teile zum Gesamtschub beitragen.
Die Russen haben das auch wieder anders gemacht. Die haben einen typischen Soyuz-Typ entwickelt. Da ist eine Zentralstufe, die vier flüssigkeitsgetriebene Triebwerke hat. Daran angeflanscht sind vier ähnliche Stufen, die aber mit der Zentralstufe auch gleichzeitig brennen. Wenn die leergebrannt sind, werden die Zusatzbooster einfach abgeworfen. Die Mittelstufe brennt dann auch ein bisschen weiter, wird dann auch später abgeworfen. Dann ist da drüber noch eine weitere Oberstufe angebracht.
Und die Rakete, die jetzt den Sputnik in die Umlaufbahn gebracht hat?
Das war auch genau dieses.
Das war dieses Soyuz-Rakete. Ja, und da war dann irgendwie in Amerika, waren sie auf einmal alle ganz nervös, weil das die Russen jetzt irgendwas über ihr Land drüber fliegen lassen können und danach befindet sich auch noch was im Weltall und es piept auch noch und alle finden das ganz cool. Das war so ein Schock, oder?
Das kann man auf jeden Fall so sagen.
Die waren irgendwie am gezittert.
Genau, also erstmal war ganz klar, dass das Problem unmöglich gewesen wäre, statt des Sputniks da eine Atomburme in die USA zu schicken. Und da haben die Amerikaner mächtig kalte Füße gekriegt.
Im Kalten Krieg.
Genau, und haben auch wirklich zur Kenntnis genommen, dass sie da erhebliche technische Defizite zu den Russen hatten zu der Zeit.
Was hat ihnen denn gefehlt?
Ja, Know-how. Also der Wernher von Braun durfte nicht mit dem nötigen Nachdruck arbeiten. Der wurde da relativ kurz gehalten. Man hat ihm da, wie man sagen muss, so unangemessen kleine Aufgaben gegeben. Der durfte da ein bisschen entwickeln, aber nicht so in dem Maßstab, wie es gerne gehabt hätte.
Und dann kam jetzt der kleine piepende Sputnik und alle hatten Angst. Und dann haben sie sich gedacht, oh Gott, jetzt graben wir den Wernher mal wieder aus.
Genau, ja. Und da hat Wernher von Brauns mächtig Rückenwind gekriegt. Das nächste Mal war die amerikanische Marine beauftragt, eine Rakete zu entwickeln, die einen Satelliten in die Umlaufbahn bringt.
Warum die Marine?
Weil die, die haben auch schon lange an militärischen Raketen gearbeitet, die auch als Kriegswaffen gedacht waren und dachten, die Marine ist da am weitesten und wir hätten vielleicht die besten Chancen, das zu machen. Weit gefehlt, die haben das also versucht und sind da ziemlich glücklich gescheitert. Und zu der Zeit hätte Werner von Braun eigentlich schon die Möglichkeiten gehabt, das da ziemlich schnell umzusetzen. Aber erst nachdem die Marine da ziemlich glücklich gescheitert ist, hat man sich dann voll auf die Unterstützung von Werner von Braun konzentriert.
Das heißt, nach Sputnik sind sie erstmal zur Marine gelatscht?
Genau, ja. Da war zunächst noch die Marine am Drücker, die hatte den Auftrag, das zu bewerkstellen, dass die Amerikaner eine Satellitenzahl kriegen. Die sind gescheitert und danach durfte Werner von Braun dann. Und der hat es gepackt.
Sputnik, das war 1957, Ende der 50er Jahre ging es irgendwie los. Und dann begann ja bei den Amerikanern diese Aufruhjagd. Dann wollten sie unbedingt die Russen irgendwie überholen. Was ich ja sehr interessant finde, ist abgesehen von diesen ganzen militärischen Nutzen, dann brach es ja, es war ja eigentlich, also die technische Leistung des Sputniks wurde ja noch überstrahlt eigentlich von diesen Propagandanutzen, den sozusagen die Sowjetunion auf einmal hatte, einfach sozusagen vorne im All zu sein. Das ist ja auch heute immer noch so dieses, also wenn man irgendwie abstrahlen will, dann einfach Weltraum. Endliche Weiten und irgendwie Sternenebel und so. Es wird diesen Nimbus auch nicht los, immer so die Zukunft der Menschheit zu repräsentieren.
Das haben die Russen wirklich sofort begriffen. Also als man die Wirkung des Sputniks beobachtet hat, hat man sofort gesagt, klasse, das machen wir jetzt weiter. Noch nie haben die Amerikaner so gezittert. Genau so war das. Das hat einen mächtigen Eindruck geschunden in der Welt. Man hat dann auch gesehen, dass das eine propagandistische Wirkung hat, die wirklich sehr gewollt war.
Und dann wollten die Amerikaner auch ein bisschen.
Und dann konnten die Amerikaner nicht zurückstehen. Und schon lief das Weltraumrennen. Was ist dann passiert? Was dann passierte, war, dass man schnell auf bemannte Flüge geguckt hat. Und auch da...
Das Rennen haben wir jetzt schon verloren. Jetzt müssen wir den ersten Mann ins All schicken.
Nee, das haben die Russen auch sehr schnell begriffen. Jetzt haben wir den Satelliten im All gehabt. Schön und gut. Aber das nächste, was kommen muss und das nächste, was wieder mächtig Eindruck schindet, das ist ein bemannte Flug. Und auch da haben die Russen, geführt von Koroliov, da sehr zielstrebig weitergearbeitet und haben dann auch sehr, sehr zügig eine Rakete und ein System fertig gekriegt, das einen Menschen heil in die Umlaufbahn brachte und wieder zurück.
Aber erst mal haben sie es mit Hunden probiert, nicht wahr? Da gab es auch hier...
Ja, Leica. Da haben sie erst mal demonstriert, dass sie ein Lebewesen heil in die Umlaufbahn bringen konnten, aber nicht wieder zurück. Das ist eine ganz andere Kiste. Aber erst mal hatten sie den armen Hund in die Umlaufbahn gekriegt und er ist auch da lebend angekommen. Aber er ist dann leider ziemlich schnell gestorben wegen technischen Problemen mit der Kapsel.
Keine Luft oder Hitze?
Ja, da ist es verschieden. Ich glaube, das Temperatoren-Regelungssystem ist nicht ausgefallen. Das war der wichtigste Grund dafür, dass die missbrauchen.
Also sie hätten schon eine Chance gehabt, den Hund auch wieder lebendig zurückzubringen, aber das hat nicht geklappt.
Nein, die hatten keine Möglichkeit vorgesehen, den Satelliten mit Hund wieder heil in die Erdaposphäre zurückzubringen.
Ach so, der Hund war sozusagen verloren.
Ja, genau.
Schade.
Ja, drum gelaufen für den Hund.
Aber immerhin, erstes Liebewesen im Weltall. Und den ersten Menschen haben die Russen dann aber auch abgesetzt.
Auf jeden Fall, ja. Und das war eigentlich eine technische Leistung, die noch viel spektakulärer war als der erste Start der Satelliten. Also das ist wirklich eine ausgesprochen trickreiche Angelegenheit, erstmal Satelliten wieder aus der Umlaufbahn zurückzubringen und dann dafür zu sorgen, dass der Satellit dann, wenn er auf dem Rückweg zur Erde ist, dass er da nicht verglüht.
Ja. Und wie haben die Russen das gemacht?
Zunächst mal braucht man einen zweiten Raketenmotor, der den Satelliten erstmal abbremst. Denn wenn man das nicht tut, umkreist er weiter die Erde. Das wäre auch dem Jury Gagarin passiert, wenn da dieser Raketenzündung nicht stattgefunden hätte. Da hat man so einen kleinen Kompromiss gemacht. Man hat die Satelliten, man hat diese Rakete bzw. dieser diplomante Raumschiff nur so hochgeschossen, dass es wenige Tage gedauert hätte, bis er von alleine wieder runtergekommen wäre. Das wäre aber unwahrscheinlich gewesen, dass das wirklich gut gegangen wäre. Wie gesagt, hätte erst mal ein paar Tage gedauert, dann wären die Ressourcen, also das Essen und Wasser und alles ziemlich knapp geworden. Atem, Luft, das wäre haarscharf, überhaupt nur gut gegangen, den Unterunlaufband rauszubringen.
Aber es war trotzdem so ein bisschen ihr Backup. Wenn es jetzt nicht funktioniert, dann können wir ihn zumindest ordentlich bestatten.
Ja, und dann wäre diese Kapsel irgendwo auf der weiten Welt runtergegangen. Wahrscheinlich mit Tough Luck mitten im Pazifik, wo er garantiert niemals gefunden worden wäre. Also das war schon eine riskante Angelegenheit.
Im Prinzip war das auch nur eine Rakete mit mehreren Stufen, wie wir es schon besprochen haben. Und der oberste Teil war dann da, wo er drin saß.
Er saß selber in einer Kugel drin, die einen Durchmesser von drei Metern hatte. Diese Kugel war dann auch mit den Lebenserhaltungsmitteln ausgerüstet. Da gab es eine Atemluftversorgung und Temperatursteuerung, die dafür gesorgt hat, dass der Herr Gagarin da ein paar Stunden drin aushalten konnte. Das nächste wichtige Element war die Möglichkeit, wie gesagt, diese Bremsrakete zu zünden. Die musste in die richtige Richtung gezündet werden. Das heißt, gegen die Flugrichtung, um den Satelliten abzubremsen, hätte man das in die Flugrichtung gezündet, wäre die Umlaufbahn ein bisschen größer geworden. Diese Backup-Bremsmöglichkeit durch die Atmosphäre wäre dadurch auch ausgefallen. Das war also auch eine katastrophale Fehlleistung gewesen. Man musste also die Lage richtig steuern können, während dieser Bremsraketen-Zündung. Und nachdem das geschafft war, musste man natürlich dafür sorgen, dass...
Da kam dann auch wieder so ein Kreitel zum Einsatz.
Nee, die haben das sehr trickreich gemacht. Die haben sich da an der Sonne orientiert. Die hatten da Sonnensensoren. Und diese Sonnensensoren haben dafür gesorgt, dass dieses Raumschiff dann beim Zünden der Rakete eine bestimmte Ausrichtung relativ zur Sonne hatte.
Das ist ja richtig trickreich.
Aber hallo.
Lichtsensoren, was haben die da verwendet?
Kann ich dir nicht genau sagen. Das waren irgendwelche Halbleiter-Elemente schon. Tatsächlich. Und das hat natürlich erhebliche Beschränken. Das heißt, was man beim Start schon daran denken musste, dass beim Zünden der Bremsraketen, die das Raumschiff nicht tatsächlich an der Nachtseite gerade ist, dann hätte das natürlich nicht geklappt. Das musste man also dringend benutzt.
Aber es ist denn gelungen. Das heißt, die Rakete hat dann richtig gezündet, hat die Kapsel wieder abgebremst. Wie hoch war er dann? Aber schon auf jenseits dieser 100 Kilometer?
Ja, ja, deutlich. Das waren 250 Kilometer, vielleicht, konnte ich mir denken.
Und was, da ist ja dann, also ab 100 Kilometer ist sozusagen keine Atmosphäre mehr, da ist sozusagen kaum noch Luft. Oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Ja, also wenn man da einen Satelliten hat, dann hält es, dann hält es der, dann hält es der, ein paar Tage hält es in der Umlaufbahn aus, aber dann wird die Lufttreibung doch schon so spürbar, dass du den Satelliten so abbringst, dass er dann irgendwann ziemlich schnell dann auch zur Erde zurückkommt.
Aber bei 250 Kilometer nicht mehr?
Doch, also dieser Effekt ist dann schon noch spürbar. Man hat da schon eine kleine Bremsung, die sich halt auf die Dauer so auswirkt, dass der Satellit ziemlich schnell zur Erde zurückkommt. Ziemlich schnell heißt da Tage, Wochen womöglich.
Das heißt, um da wirklich zu bleiben, braucht man auch eine permanente Acceleration. Man muss dann schon auch immer wieder Gas geben. Das gilt auch für alle Satelliten.
Das ist auch bei der ISS so. Die fliegt typischerweise bei 380 km um die Erde rum. Aber auch da kann man noch eine abbremsende Wirkung feststellen und deswegen muss da ab und zu mal angeschoben werden durch Raketentriefer.
Die abbremsende Wirkung ist allein durch sozusagen Durch die ein bisschen Restatmosphäre. Restatmosphäre, Restluft, die da noch rumfliegt. Was wirklich verschwindend wenig ist, sozusagen, aber es ist halt da.
Ja, es ist klar, aber es ist eine kleine Kraft, aber Stehlertropfen höhlt den Stein und diese Abbremsung sorgt dafür, dass dann doch in absehbarer Zeit der Wiedereintritt stattfinden würde.
Das heißt, ohne Sprit ist auch da oben nichts los.
Genau, ja. Also muss man schon wirklich noch viel weiter rausfliegen, um davon wirklich, um davon wirklich sicher zu sein.
So, und als der Gargarin dann wieder abgebremst wurde, dann ist er wieder zurückgefallen. Da hat man das Problem, dass man dann wieder in die Atmosphäre eintreten muss. Da wird es warm.
Genau, da muss man sich für die damalige Zeit schon zunächtige technische Kunststücke einfallen lassen, Umhalt.
War das allen schon von vornherein so klar?
Den richtigen Leuten war das klar, ja. Also, wenn er von Brauns wusste...
Haben die das erst mit dem Hund rausbekommen?
Nein, das war schon vor Laika schon lange bekannt. Also, wenn er von Braun wusste, Herrmann Obert wusste das und Karel Roloff auf jeden Fall auch.
Okay. Das heißt, sie mussten sich da entsprechend wappnen. Das heißt, die Kugel von dem Gagarin war einfach dick oder besonders beschichtet?
Die war besonders beschichtet. Und zwar hatte man da eine sogenannte Ablationskühlung eingebaut. Das heißt eine Abschmelzkühlung. Das heißt, dass da Wärme abtransportiert wurde, indem da wirklich Material abgeschmolzen ist und dann durch das Abschmelzen auch Wärme mitgenommen hat.
Was für ein Material war das?
Irgendwelche Kunstharze waren das.
Das heißt, das war sozusagen mit so einer Harzschicht überdeckt?
Da waren auch irgendwelche Faser noch eingearbeitet.
Und das kühlt durch das Verschmelzen. Was ist das für ein Effekt?
Wenn du irgendwas schmilzt, zum Beispiel eine Kerze hast und da tropft es runter, dann sind die Tropfen ja heiß.
Und führen sozusagen Wärme ab?
Und führen durch die Tatsache, dass sie heiß sind, da schon Wärme ab. Und so wird man wärmelos.
Verstehe, das heißt, die Wärme wird sozusagen im schmelzenden Material eingespeichert und fliegt dann weg.
Genau, mit den Tropfen, ja.
Damit wird dann sozusagen die Hitze weggenommen und das haben sie sich so ausgerechnet, dass das dann irgendwie passen könnte. Hatten sie das bei Leica auch schon?
Nie, also Leica hatte gar keine Schutzverreckung.
Also es war klar, dass die verglühen, auch wenn sie sozusagen schon vorher verreckt ist.
Genau, ja.
Sie hatten ja auch noch die Möglichkeit der sonstigen technischen Probleme. Aber bei Gagarin ging das natürlich jetzt nicht. Den konnten sie irgendwie nicht in geschmolzene Zustand präsentieren.
Genau, der sollte gerne, würde nach Möglichkeit wieder strahlend da auf den roten Platz, auf den roten Platz davor geführt werden.
Ja, und das hat dann gereicht. Also diese Schmelzgeschichte war sozusagen ausreichend. Oder wurde es ihm warm?
Ja, ihm wurde es warm, da wurde es richtig warm drin. Und es gab da auch kritische technische Schwierigkeiten. Nämlich diese Kugel, die dafür gebaut war, den Wiedereintritt zu überleben, musste ja vom eigentlichen Raumschiff getrennt werden. Der Rest des Raumschiffs war zum Beispiel für die Abrämsung zuständig. Nach der Abrämsung musste dann die Kapsel abgetrennt werden. Die war mit Metallbändern an dem Rest des Raumschiffs befestigt. Diese Metallbänder haben sich zunächst nicht richtig gelöst. Was dann dazu geführt hat, dass das alles da ziemlich rumgeschlackert hat. Ja genau, das war gefährlich. Aber nachher sind diese Bänder durch die Lufttreibung zerstört worden. Gerade noch rechtzeitig, um den Wiedereintritt ordentlich ablaufen zu lassen.
Und der restliche Teil, der dann abgesprengt wird. Was heißt denn das? Ist verglüht? Also wie sehr verglüht eigentlich das Material? Wird das dann wirklich komplett, das ganze Metall und das ganze Zeug, komplett in gasförmigen Zustand überführt oder geht da immer irgendwie ein regen kleiner Teilchen nach oben?
Also das hängt ein bisschen davon ab, wie schnell das Teil beim Eintritt in die Atmosphäre ist und aus welchen Materialien das besteht, welche Dichte die haben. Also wenn man zum Beispiel irgendwelche stabilen Metallteile hat in einem Raumfahrzeug, die kommen auch gerne mal auf der Erdaberfläche an. Das ist durchaus nicht ungewöhnlich.
Und bei dem Gagarin?
Beim Gagarin war das, also von dem Rest der Kapsel ist zumindest kein Trauma-Stück bekannt.
Also ist es schon wahrscheinlich, dass es wirklich komplett verglüht ist? Und dann kam er an und wurde da wieder ausgepackt, ist er irgendwo in der Tundra gelandet?
Nee, nee, der, also die Kapsel ist erstmal am Fallschirm dann hintergegangen, ja. Und kurz vor dem Einschlag, der wirklich ungemütlich geworden wäre, hat er sich mit dem Schleudersitz da rausgeschossen, so wie man sich heutzutage aus einem Düsenjäger rausschießen würde.
Und dann nochmal mit einem extra falschen Schleudersitz. Und die Kapsel ist dann noch mit einer relativ ungemütlichen Geschwindigkeit runtergeknallt.
Genau, ja.
Und dann saß er da irgendwie auf dem Acker, dann kam sie mit ihren großen Hubschraubern, haben ihn eingesammelt.
Nee, so genau war das nicht. Also ich glaube, er musste tatsächlich erstmal irgendwo anrufen.
Anrufen? So ein Funk-Sender wird er dabei gehabt haben oder so?
Weiß ich nicht genau, aber ich glaube tatsächlich wurden die Rettungskräfte da angerufen, wenn ich mich recht entsinne. Das heißt, er hat sich da über irgendwelchen Bauern gemeldet. Ja, und da wurde, glaube ich, telefoniert.
Und wenn da jetzt keine Bauern gewesen wären?
Also so genau hat man schon... Also man hat gesagt, man konnte das Zielgebiet ja schon relativ eingrenzen, weil man beim Abbremsen relativ gut gezielt hat. Man hätte einfach suchen müssen. Also er hatte wohl auch ein Funkgerät dabei, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das...
Aber hat er nicht... Ich meine, er war im Orbit und hat ja sozusagen die Erde auch wirklich ein paar Mal umrundet.
Einmal.
Einmal. Einmal und wieder runter. Wie konnte man denn mit der Technik damals überhaupt timen, wo er dann sozusagen runtergegangen ist? Haben die dann irgendwie an den Himmel geguckt und haben gesagt, da kommt er, jetzt drücken wir mal auf die Taste oder war das... Haben sie das dann auch mit ihren Sonnensensoren gemacht, wenn die Sonne so und so steht, dann müssten wir da und da sein? Also war das sozusagen so voll automatisch oder?
Ich glaube, das war wirklich mit dem mit dem Zeitschalter-Mechanismus irgendwie gesteuert.
Ah, weil sie jetzt sozusagen, ja okay, mit ihren Berechnungen relativ klar wussten, wie lange man braucht.
Genau, ja.
Pfiffig und dann sozusagen auch noch das ganze Landegebiet damit klar umgrenzen. Das hat funktioniert. Kein Wunder, dass die Amerikaner so beeindruckt waren.
Ja, die hatten auch einige Monate nach dem Start von Yuri Gagarin dann ihren ersten Flug. Da ist Alan Shepard mit einer Mörkierkapsel ins All geflogen. Aber das war wirklich technisch deutlich weniger eindrucksvoll, als das, was die Russen gezeigt hatten. Also, Shepard hat nicht die Umlaufbahn erreicht. Er wurde einfach nur hochgeschossen, irgendwie 180 Kilometer hoch und dann gleich wieder runter. Er hat keine Umlaufbahn erreicht und hat sich von daher einige technische Probleme erspart, die die Russen da elegant gelöst haben.
Und dann wollten die Amerikaner natürlich unbedingt aufholen. Das war ja irgendwie ihr erklärtes Ziel. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wer die treibende Kraft war. Ich erinnere mich irgendwie an Kennedy, der dann irgendwann bekannt gegeben hat, so geht es jetzt nicht weiter.
Ja, also die Amerikaner waren da bei den Flügen in die Erdumlaufbahn da, also immer mehrere Schritte hinter den Russen her. Also da war ein ganz klares Leistungsgefälle, muss man sagen. Und irgendwie haben die Amerikaner dann erkannt, dass sie auf die Tour nicht nach vorne kommen. Und da haben sie dann gesagt, okay, wir machen jetzt, wir kündigen jetzt den richtig großen Schlag an. Und da haben sie schon wenige Monate nach diesem wenig beeindruckenden Flug von Alan Shepard da öffentlich angekündigt, dass sie zum Mond fliegen wollen.
Nach dem Motto, wir drücken jetzt mal voll auf die Tube.
Genau.
Und es kümmert sich unsere Nation erstmal um nichts anderes mehr. Wir haben dann irgendwie einen, ja, erklecklichen Teil ihres Nationenetats auf die Raumfahrt geworfen. Und das hat ja dann auch tatsächlich Wirkung gezeigt.
Ja, also das war wirklich sehr, sehr eindrucksvoll. Also wie man da in wie kurzer Zeit man von 0 auf 100 kommen kann, wenn Geld keine Rolle spielt.
Was haben Sie dann, was waren denn dann sozusagen der Durchbruch? Also woran hat es denn den Amerikanern eigentlich gefehlt? Also an Ideen oder an Basistechnologie? Oder einfach nur am Geld, um einfach genug Leute in Bewegung zu setzen?
Ja, so an Motivation, würde ich sagen, hat es da zunächst gefehlt. Da war man immer nur der Zweite und da ist man nicht richtig aus dem Puschen gekommen. Erst als wirklich das Ziel gesteckt war, als sichergestellt war, dass da die Ressourcen zur Verfügung stehen, da kam das in die Puschen.
Das war dann sozusagen auch der Tag für Wernher von Braun?
Genau.
Weil das wollte er nun schon immer noch machen. Der war dann auch die treibende Kraft nach wie vor?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Der war für die Raketenentwicklung im wesentlichen zuständig. Und ohne die Ingenieursfähigkeit von Wernher von Braun hätte es sicherlich nicht geklappt. Und erst 1965 kann man sagen, dass die Amerikaner wirklich den Russen überlegen waren. Da gab es nämlich das Gemini-Programm. Das war ganz klar maßgeschneidert, um in der Erdumlaufbahn einige Technologien zu entwickeln oder zu testen, die man für den Mondklub braucht, so Navigationsfragen und Steuerungsfragen. Dafür waren die Gemini-Raumschiffe gebaut. Die hatten schon zwei Astronauten an Bord. Und die hatten ganz klar Fähigkeiten, die die Russen eigentlich nicht hatten zu der Zeit.
Was war das?
Die Steuerbarkeit und die, also die Navigierbarkeit und Kommunikationstechniken und Navigationstechniken, das war es.
Das heißt, um sozusagen, wenn man erstmal im Orbit schwebt, zu wissen, wo man ist.
Genau, dass man da die Fähigkeit hat, mit einem anderen Raumfahrzeug zu docken. Diese Fähigkeit wurde entwickelt und dergleichen mehr.
Was haben die da miteinander andocken lassen?
Diese Gemini-Kapsel ist eine Zwei-Mann-Kapsel. Die hat man zunächst mal in die Nähe von unbemannten Oberstufen gebracht, die da noch rumflogen. Später hat man dann...
Die noch rumflogen?
Ja.
Wie so Schrott?
Weltraum-Schrott, könnte man sagen. Und dann gab es einen Rendezvous-Flug mit zwei bemannten Kapseln. Die sind auf wenige Meter aneinander rangekommen. Und dann hat man auch wirklich speziell zu diesen zweikrochgeschossenen Targets angedockt. Das waren also spezielle Oberstufen, die einen Adapter hatten, an dem sich die Gemini-Kapsel da einklinken konnte. Das hat man auch gemacht.
Warum ist denn diese Dockerei jetzt so wichtig für einen Mondflug?
Weil man festgestellt hat, dass es nur so geht, dass man zunächst mit einem Verbund aus zwei Raumschiffen zum Mond fliegt, dort in diesen Verbund aus zwei Raumschiffen in die Mondumlaufbahn einschwenkt. Und ein Teil dieses Verbundes bleibt dann in der Mondumlaufbahn, während der andere Teil dann zur Monduhrfläche absteigt. Und das bedingt natürlich auch, dass man nach der Rückkehr von der Monduhrfläche wieder an diesen zurückgebliebenen Teil da andocken kann.
Klar, damit man auch wieder zurückkommt.
Ja, man muss erst mal finden, man muss dann dahin steuern können und muss sich auch so geschickt verhalten, dass man auch wieder andocken kann. Das ist wirklich ein erhebliches technisches Problem, das hinzukriegen, in jeder Hinsicht.
Was war denn dann der Plan von den Amerikanern oder Wernher von Braun und seinem Team? Wie wollten sie es machen und wie haben sie es dann letzten Endes gemacht um diesen Mondflug?
Der Plan war klar, der wurde von der Rede von Präsident Kennedys aus dem Jahr 1961 klargegeben.
Das ist die Absichtserklärung, aber was war der technische Plan? Was wollten sie zum Einsatz bringen? Was haben sie am Ende zum Einsatz gebracht? War das wirklich der erste Entwurf, den sie sich ausgedacht haben? Das war dann auch das, was am Ende funktioniert hat? Man musste das halt nur so lange testen, bis man es auch funktionieren bekommt? Oder mussten da noch verschiedene Konzepte verworfen werden?
Man wollte das zunächst einmal mit der Vorschlagrahmen-Methode bauen. Die Alternative zu diesem Prinzip, das ich eben geschildert habe, nämlich mit dem Docking in der Mondumlaufbahn, wäre gewesen, eine riesengroße Rakete zu bauen, die praktisch ohne diesen Zwischenstopp in der Mondumlaufbahn da direkt auf der Mondumlauffläche gelandet wäre, dann zurückgestartet wäre und an einem Stück wieder zur Erde zurückgeflogen wäre. So wollte man das ursprünglich machen. Und man hat dann ziemlich schnell festgestellt, dass das eine gewaltig große Rakete bedingt hätte. Okay, dann war eben eine riesengroße Rakete. Und nachdem man sich da ein bisschen mit diesem Bau der riesengroßen Rakete auseinandergesetzt hat, hat man sich gedacht, hu, vielleicht ist das doch ein bisschen zu viel. Aber dann wiederum erschien dieses Docking in der Mondumlaufbahn technisch derartig riskant, dass man sich da auch nicht richtig herangetraut hatte. Und da war man ein bisschen in der Zwickmühle dann.
Aber mit dem Gemini-Projekt haben Sie ja sozusagen bewiesen, dass es irgendwie geht?
Ja, aber damit hat man halt erst mal gezeigt, dass es in der Erdumlaufbahn geht. Die ganze Sache da in der Mondumlaufbahn zu machen, ist noch mal eine Kiste, die ganz anders ist. Weil da einige Ressourcen nicht zur Verfügung steht, die man in der Erdumlaufbahn hat. Zum Beispiel nicht die Informationen von erdgebundenen Bodenstationen. Oder in anderer Form zumindest, aber nicht so günstiger Form.
Also man kann nicht so einfach hinfunken und auch nicht so gut beobachten von der Erde. Was heißt am Ende, das war das Apollo-Programm, was letzten Endes erfolgreich war. War jetzt die erste Apollo-Rakete, flog auch schon. Es gab ja mehrere Apollo-Missionen. Die ersten flogen erstmal nur zum Mond.
Man fing erstmal an mit deinem Flug einfach in die Erdumlaufbahn. Das war Apollo 7. Die sind erstmal nur mit dem Apollo-Raumschiff ohne Mondlandefähre in die Erdumlaufbahn geflogen, um das da auszuprobieren. Dann kam 1968, im Dezember 1968, Apollo 8. Das war gleich ein Flug zum Mond, allerdings ohne Mondlandefähre wieder. Aber man hat erst mal Astronauten zum Mond gebracht, in eine Mondumlaufbahn und hat auch wieder halt zurückgebracht. Dann kam Apollo 9, Jahre 1969, Anfang 1969. Die sind wiederum in die Erdumlaufbahn geflogen, hatten aber schon die Mondlandefähre dabei. Da hat man so das Docking in der Erdumlaufbahn erstmal geübt.
Das heißt, sie haben diese Mondlandefähre schon ausgespuckt und dann wieder angedockt?
Genau, die haben sich getrennt und diese Navigation auch geübt. Man hat auch nachgewiesen, dass die Mondlandefähre tatsächlich ein eigenständiges und funktionsfähiges Raumfahrzeug ist. Das war also gut. Das war abgehakt. Denn der nächste Schritt war Apollo 10. Das war ein Flug zum Mond wiederum, aber diesmal mit dem vollen Programm, mit Apollo-Raumschiff und Mondlandefähre. Die haben sich getrennt und sind wieder zusammengekommen. Das einzige, was tatsächlich gefehlt hat, war die Landung auf den Mond. Das hat man sich für Apollo 11 aufbewahrt.
Weil man sich einfach noch nicht so sicher war und man wollte sozusagen überhaupt erstmal den Dockingvorgang in der Mondumlaufbahn machen. Und in dieser Fähre war dann aber auch niemand drin.
Doch, da waren Leute drin, da waren zwei Astronauten drin, die genau das gemacht haben, was die Mondländer später gemacht haben. Bis auf die Landung selber. Das wäre ohne Menschen vollkommen unmöglich gewesen. Die Computer waren seinerzeit bei weitem nicht in Lage, diese Navigationsaufgaben zu erledigen, die die Menschen an Bord erledigt haben.
Das heißt, die Astronauten, die müssten auch wirklich gut ausgebildet sein mit mathematischen Kenntnissen oder haben die einfach so auf Sicht gearbeitet?
Das waren schlaue Leute und die mussten auch schlau sein, denn diese ganzen Navigationsaufgaben waren durchaus anspruchsvoll. Sie hatten aber auch richtig gut zu tun.
Und mit Apollo 11 haben sie es dann sozusagen geschafft?
Ja.
Auch wenn ja manche sagen, das wäre ja alles gar nicht so gewesen und es wäre ja alles nur so ein Film von Stanley Kubrick gewesen.
Ja, die haben es geschafft und die waren tatsächlich da. Diese Verschwörungstheorien, da kann man doch mit dem Kopf schütteln.
Was sind denn die unwiderlegbaren Beweise, dass die Mondmission tatsächlich stattgefunden hat?
Der unwiderlegbare Beweis ist erstmal das Schweigen der Russen. Die hatten auf jeden Fall die technischen Möglichkeiten, die Apollo-Raumflüge zu verfolgen. Die hatten die ganze Infrastruktur, die man braucht, um alles Mögliche da nachzuvollziehen.
Wie weit waren die denn?
Die wollten auch zum Mond unter der Führung von Koroljow. Die haben eine Mondlandeferre gebaut, die man heute noch in Moskau besichtigen kann. Die haben Rakete gebaut, die sich neben der Saturn V-Rakete nicht verstecken mussten. Die war genauso hoch, genauso schwer, hatte ähnliche Leistungsdaten. Bloß diese Mondraketen haben sie nie zum Laufen gebracht. Das war eine sehr offentliche Angelegenheit, die Saturn V natürlich auch. Bloß die Herren und keiner haben ganz zu Anfang eine wargemutige Konstruktionsentscheidung getroffen, vor der die Russen zurückgeschreckt haben. Die haben sich dann gemacht, diese Saturn V-Rakete mit wenigen, aber riesengroßen und sehr leistungsstärken Triebwerken zu bauen. Die Russen haben das anders gemacht. Sie haben gedacht, sie könnten 30 kleinere Triebwerke nehmen, um damit die erste Stufe zu betreiben. Da war auf den ersten Blick nachvollziehbar diese Entscheidung. Weil diese kleineren Triebwerke erst mal beherrschbar waren, dachte man, diese Technik war bekannt, und die haben sich gedacht, warum nicht 30 von diesen kleinen Triebwerken nehmen? Das muss doch klappen. Wir haben den gleichen Schub. Bloß was die Russen bei dieser Entscheidung tragischerweise übersehen haben, war die vibrationstechnische Einflussung dieser Triebwerke untereinander. Das haben die überhaupt nicht in den Griff gekriegt. Im Wesentlichen aus diesem Grunde sind den Russen dann vier dieser schweren Trägerraketen vorn. Glück beim Staat.
Weil die einfach so gezittert und vibriert haben, sich gegenseitig und dann sind sie einfach auseinandergegangen.
Genau das Problem war, wenn auf der einen Seite der Rakete ein Triebwerk ausfiel, musste man, um den Schub balancieren zu können, auf der Gegenseite das andere Triebwerk dann gleichzeitig ausschalten. Und da hat es dann zu einer Kettenreaktion geführt, die dafür gesorgt hat, dass das nicht geklappt hat.
Du sagst im Prinzip, wenn die Amerikaner da nicht da gewesen wären, dann hätten die Russen das schon lautstark zur Kenntnis gegeben.
Die Russen hätten das erstens gemerkt, mit Sicherheit. Die wurden durch die Mondlandung als technisch zweitklassig vorgeführt. Und die haben erstmal aus technischem Interesse alles beobachtet, was da vor sich ging. Und die hätten auf jeden Fall auch das propagandistische Interesse daran gehabt, irgendwelche Sachen, die da nicht stattgefunden haben, der Öffentlichkeit zu melden. Der Leonid Brezhnev hätte das sicherlich an die größte verfügbare Glocke gehängt, wenn es da zumindest auch nur Zweifel gegeben hätte, dass das irgendwie gemacht wurde. Man weiß ja auch heutzutage, was die Russen, was für einen gewaltigen Spionagekomplex die Russen da unterhalten haben. Der KGB ist die größte denkbare Spionageorganisation gewesen. Und die haben da allein schon für den KGB einen erheblichen Anteil ihres Volksbrutoprodukts, Sozialprodukts da ausgegeben. Und dieser Mechanismus war ausgesprochen effektiv. Also die haben innerhalb kürzester Zeit die Geheimnisse der Atombombe ausspioniert und da in den engsten, eng abgeschirmten Kenntniskreis der Atombombe eingedrungen. Das war bei Apodosatoren ganz anders. Also da waren viel mehr Leute beschäftigt in der Entwicklung als bei der Atombombe und es wäre entsprechend leichter gewesen, da Spionage technisch einzudringen. Und das werden die auch gemacht haben. Die werden sicherlich bestens über die technischen Vorgänge mit gewesen sein und die hätten das sofort mitgekriegt, wenn da irgendwas getürkt wird. Es wäre nicht nur eine Mission gewesen, die nicht stattgefunden hätten. Man hätte ja auch andere unbemannte Missionen zum Mond hinschicken müssen, um das Mondgestein zu beschaffen, das man der Weltöffentlichkeit präsentiert hat. Und man hat auch Sensoren hingestellt, die man heutzutage von der Erde noch nachweisen kann. Es gibt so Laser-Retro-Reflektoren, die man heutzutage noch mit dem Laser anleuchten kann. Dann kriegt man einen Lichtimpuls zurück.
Ah, da liegen einfach so Spiegel rum sozusagen.
Ja, die müssen aber ordentlich aufgestellt und ausgerichtet sein. Also so einfach ist das nicht.
Ich dachte nicht, dass es jetzt natürliche Mondspiegel gibt.
Na genau. Das Reflektieren dieses Lasers von der Mondoberfläche funktioniert nicht. Die Verschwörungshaini ist überhaupt nicht ausständig. Das ist aber falsch. Das funktioniert einfach nicht. Man kriegt kein Laser-Signal zurück, wenn man einfach nur die Mondoberfläche anleuchtet.
Piffig, worauf die auch immer wieder alles kommen. Wenn man so damit beschäftigt ist, überhaupt erst mal hinzufliegen, dann gleich beim ersten Flug, was man alles hinterlassen könnte, was später noch mal interessant sein sollte. Ich bin immer wieder erstaunt, was alles so vorbereitet wird. Du hast gesagt, die Russen hatten ja auch alle Möglichkeiten zu beobachten, was da passiert. Es stellt sich mir natürlich die Frage, was ist denn überhaupt an Infrastruktur auf der Erde notwendig, um jetzt einen solchen Flug zu begleiten? Man braucht natürlich die Technik in der Rakete. Das Ding muss sich irgendwie steuern. Das muss sich selber regeln, ein Stück weit autonom oder zumindest von der Mannschaft vor Ort, so es eine gibt, bedienbar sein. In gewisser Hinsicht natürlich auch fernsteuerbar. Klar, da hat man dann eine Funkverbindung. Aber was hat sich parallel zu der eigentlichen Raketen, Flug, Andock und Landetechnologie als Infrastruktur auf der Erde entwickelt, damit man solche Raummissionen beobachten, messen, retten, generell steuern kann?
Ja, man braucht zunächst mal Bodenstationen, und zwar eine ganze Reihe von denen. Denn du weißt ja, dass der Mond auf und unter geht. In einem bestimmten Ort, wenn wir hier in Darmstadt sitzen, dann geht der Mond auf und wieder unter. Und wir brauchen, da können wir uns nicht halten. Wir müssen also auf der anderen Seite der Welt auch noch Bodenstationen unterhalten, die übernehmen, wenn der Mond hier untergegangen ist.
Wie sieht so eine Bodenstation aus?
Das ist in der Regel eine Satellitenschüssel, ziemlich groß. Für den Mond reicht heutzutage eine Schüssel von ein paar Metern Durchmesser. Ab früher hat man noch richtig große Schüsseln gebraucht, weil man noch nicht die Hochfrequenztechnik hatte, die man heute hat.
Das heißt, diese großen Dinger, die man immer aus diesen Bildern kennt, die auch ein bisschen symbolhaft stehen für die Raumfahrttechnik auf der Erde, wenn man von den Raketen absieht, die waren damals schon sehr groß. Im Sinne von 20, 30 Meter Durchmesser.
Oder noch größer.
Um einfach die Signale so gut bündeln zu können, damit sie auch, wenn sie noch ganz schwach angefunkt kommen, auswertbar sind.
Genau, ja. 25 bis 30 Meter hat man damals schon gebraucht, um die Datenmengen da...
War das damals schon sozusagen digitaler Funk? Und was wurde so da gefunkt? Also, wenn es Anweisungen sind, muss ja schon irgendeine digitale Information da drin enthalten sein? Oder sind wirklich die einzelnen Elemente auch analog gesteuert worden?
Es wurde im wesentlichen Datenaustausch gemacht. Also zunächst mal wurden die Bodensstationen benutzt, um die Flugbahnen zu vermessen. Und aus diesen Messdaten hat man dann irgendwelche Korrekturmanöver, gegebenenfalls berechnet. Und die Daten dieser Korrekturmanöver hat man dann den Astronauten weitergegeben. Padway, in dem man Zahlenkolonnen da...
Was heißt die Flugbahn gemessen? Also hat man nur Empfang, was die Rakete selbst misst, wie sie fliegt oder ist das schon so eine... Ist das nur so, dass sie so Funksignale ausländet und daran, wie die Signale ankommen, misst man?
Also um die Bahn zu vermessen, braucht man Informationen über die Bewegung der Sonde und den Ort. Erstmal die Entfernung, in die man so einen Ping hochschickt zum Raumflugkörper. Und der wird dann von einem Transponder an Bord des Raumfahrzeugs zurückgeworfen. Und aus der Gesamtlaufzeit kann man dann die Entfernung der Sonde berechnen. Man kennt die Lichtgeschwindigkeit und man weiß, welchen Delay der Transponder da an Bord hat. Und daraus kann man dann die Entfernung messen. Des Weiteren kann man noch die Geschwindigkeit messen, denn durch dieses hin und her Schicken gibt es noch eine Dopplerverschiebung. Und dadurch kann man wirklich eine sehr präzise Messung der Relativgeschwindigkeit auch machen. Und aus diesen beiden Informationen kann man dann die Umlaufbahn berechnen.
Vor allem, wenn man sozusagen über die Zeit das immer wiederholt und dann in mehreren Schritten sieht, alles klar, wir sind irgendwie auf dem Wege.
Ja, und so wusste man dann, auf welcher Umlaufbahn die Astronauten gerade waren. Und man wusste, wo man hinwollte auf welche Bahn. Und man hat dann entsprechend mit der Computerkapazität auf der Erde die Daten für das Manöver berechnet. Und die dann einfach als Zahlenkolonnen an die Astronauten weitergegeben.
Mhm, also per Sprache.
Ja genau, die haben einfach Zahlenkolonnen da durchgefunkt und die wurden dann...
Da saß da einfach so ein HINI und hätte die ganze Zeit 1, 5, 9, 7, 3, 8...
Ja genau, an Bord der Apollo-Kapsel wurden diese Zahlenkolonnen dann in irgendwelche Formblätter übertragen und die hat dann alle Informationen erhalten, die man an Bord braucht, um einen Korrekturmanöver zu machen.
Und dann wurde das über irgendwelche Schalter wieder in die Apparate reingeklackert.
Es gab da auch Computer an Bord, aber die wird man heutzutage kaum noch als Computer bezeichnen. Die Computerleistung an Bord der Apollo-Kapsel wurde heute von jedem Handy übertroffen.
Oh ja, von den Handys auf jeden Fall schon.
Ja, von der Armaduhr womöglich.
Ja, das wollte ich sagen. Und...
Oder vom Radio weg.
Nachdem diese Mondlandung dann gelaufen war, war ja so ein bisschen... Man hatte das Gefühl, jetzt ist irgendwie alles erreicht worden. Ich war danach... ist das ja ganz schön abgeflaut.
Auf jeden Fall ja. Das Problem war nach der Mondlandung konnte eigentlich erst mal nicht mehr viel kommen. Die einzige Möglichkeit, das zu toppen, wäre dann der Flug zum Mars gewesen. Da hat man auch drüber nachgedacht, aber man hat dann schnell eingesehen, dass das doch dann an die technischen Möglichkeiten auch der USA überschreitet. Und vor allem auch die finanziellen Möglichkeiten zu der Zeit.
Und ich denke, man hat sich nach diesen ganzen Ausgaben auch mal darüber Gedanken gemacht, was man jetzt vielleicht mit dieser ganzen erworbene Technik machen kann, außer Propaganda.
Ja, da gab es schon sehr gute Anbindung. Also, man faselt ja immer von der Teflon-Fanne, die wir der Raumfahrt zu verdanken haben.
Haben wir sich der Raumfahrt zu verdanken?
Nee, haben wir nicht. Die gab es schon vorher. Also, die Teflon-Fannen, die kann man aus der Liste streichen, was man tatsächlich von der Apollo-Mission hat, von dem ganzen Technologieschub, der in diesem Zusammenhang entwickelt worden ist. Da hat man zunächst einmal die Computertechnik, die hat wirklich einen gewaltigen Schub nach vorne gekriegt. Man hat etliche Raumfahrt-Techniken entwickelt, die seinerzeit dazu geführt haben, dass die Amerikanern auch bei der kommerziellen Nutzung des Weltraums da die Nase vorn hatten. Die haben also Technologien entwickelt, die zur Entwicklung von Telekommunikationssatelliten geführt haben, mit denen man richtig gut Geld verdienen kann, mit denen man Fernsehsignale und Telefongespräche übertragen kann.
Das war ja dann im Prinzip das, und ist auch heute eigentlich noch, das ist ja eigentlich das Business der Raumfahrt, oder?
Eigentlich schon, ja. Telekommunikation ist heute eine sehr wichtige Anwendung. Und wie gesagt, diese Technologien, die man dazu braucht, die wurden eigentlich bei Apollo entwickelt.
Und natürlich auch darüber hinaus. Aber das war dann sozusagen das, wovon dann die 70er, 80er Jahre im Wesentlichen geprägt war. Satelliten hochschießen, ohne Ende, Kommunikationsnetzwerke aufbauen, Satellitentelefonie aufbauen, natürlich auch Spionage, keine Ahnung, was sonst alles noch rumliegt. Dann, wann ist denn, also wenn ich jetzt so ein bisschen, ich bin ja hier heute auch durch die Kontrollräume marschiert und habe erstmal so ein bisschen Überblick gemacht, was jetzt hier bei der ESA auch konkret zum Einsatz kommt. Wenn ich es richtig verstehe, kann man ja im Prinzip die Missionen aufteilen, erstmal so ganz grob in Missionen, die sich um die Erde kümmern. Sachen, die also die Erde umrunden, beobachten, auswerten, fotografieren, messen, was weiß ich, was hier im Einzelnen auch ist, kannst du ja gleich mal ausführen. Und dann eben das, was sich sozusagen in die Ferne richtet, sozusagen von der Erde weg. Also andere Planeten genauso vermessen, wie man das mit der Erde macht oder sonst irgendwo hinfliegen und nachgucken bzw. in die Ferne schauen, in Richtung Urknall gucken, überhaupt bunte Bilder fotografieren. Und was ich ja besonders scharf finde, ist ja hier, wie heißt er noch gleich, der Kometenverfolger?
Rosetta.
Rosetta, genau. Da ist ja hier auch so eine schöne Replika, bzw. also nicht wirklich eine Replika, sondern wie nennt man das, ein Ingenieurs-Modell, wo man dann immer selber schon mal vor Ort dran rumbasteln kann, damit man weiß, wie man es dann in der Fernsteuerung auch macht. Kannst du mal ein bisschen was sagen zu der Ausrichtung, wenn man jetzt ein bisschen in die Gegenwart schaut, womit sich die Raumfahrt jetzt eigentlich im Wesentlichen beschäftigt, vielleicht erstmal mit dem Blickwinkel der ESA?
Die ESA beschäftigt sich eigentlich mit allen Aspekten der Raumfahrt. Also die ESA kümmert sich um Erdbeobachtungen. Es gibt einige Satelliten, die die Erde umkreisen, um die Erde zu beobachten. Da haben wir neulich den Gojo hochgeschickt. Das ist ein extrem moderner Satellit, der sehr nah bei der Erde fliegt. So nah, dass da schon die Lufttreibung spürbar ist.
Wie nah ist das dann?
250 Kilometer. Da hat man schon eine Bremse.
Also so Gargarienhöhe.
Genau, ja. Und wenn man da fliegt, dann muss man unterbleiben. Da muss man aktiv ausunternehmen, um in der Umlaufbahn zu bleiben. Deswegen hat er ein Ionen-Triebwerk, das über lange Zeit räume, das heißt, zwei Jahre vielleicht einen kleinen Schub liefert, dann kann man das auszugleichen.
Das ist ja eine relativ neue Geschichte, diese Ionen-Antriebe.
Das ist neu und das ist auch von der ESA erheblich mitentwickelt worden.
Mit diesem Smart-Projekt wurde das eigentlich mal ursprünglich getestet. Das war aber ein Mondflug, oder?
Das war ein Mondflug, ja. Aber der Sinn und Zweck war eigentlich im Wesentlichen das technische Ausprobieren dieser Ionenantriebe.
Und das ist sozusagen im Prinzip die grüne Technologie der Raumfahrt, weil da nicht mehr fossile Brennstoffe verdonnert werden, sondern das Ding sondert, ja, was eigentlich ab, wodurch entsteht das?
Da kommt ein Strahl aus extrem hoch, also ein Strahl aus extrem schnellen Edelgasatomen kommt da raus. Hat mit Umweltfreundlichkeit, hat es da keine Motivation, möchte einfach neue technische Möglichkeiten eröffnen. Nämlich die Alternative zu einem Ion-Triebwerk wäre ein klassisches chemisches Triebwerk, das man gelegentlich zünden kann. Das ist in mancherlei Hinsicht sehr viel weniger effektiv. Man kann da kurze, aber kräftige Schubs mit produzieren. Aber diese Ion-Triebwerke haben die Möglichkeit, über extrem lange Zeiträume einen schwächeren Schub zu produzieren.
Also der Unterschied, ob man sein Spielzeugauto mit einem Schienerböller oder mit einem Duschstrahl so produziert?
Ja, genau so. Mit diesem Ion-Triebwerk hat man ganz andere technische Möglichkeiten. Man kann da interessante Ziele effektiv erreichen.
Das heißt, es sind niedrige Schübe, aber sie sind halt permanent und daher auch gut dosierbar und reichen aus, auf jeden Fall um diese Restluft, die bei 250 Kilometer noch vorhanden ist, einfach zu überwinden.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Das ist aber jetzt auch nicht so ein riesiger Satellit.
Nein, es ist ein sehr kleiner, schlanker Satellit. Der Satellit ist vier, fünf Meter lang und sieht aus wie ein Bleistift. Hinten ein Leitwerk wie ein Flugzeug. Das ist auch die gleiche Funktion wie beim Flugzeug. Da treten tatsächlich schon schwache Steuerdrehmomente aus, die man da ausnutzt. Der Ziel und Zweck dieses Satelliten ist, nah bei der Erde zu fliegen, um das schwere Feld der Erde genau zu beobachten. Ich möchte gerne wissen, wie die Erde aufgebaut ist, wie die Masse in der Erde genau verteilt ist. Das kann man auf der Erderfläche nicht so genau messen, wie auf der Erder- und Luftbahn.
Das ist dieser Geoid, dass die Erde ja eigentlich nicht wirklich im einlichen Sinne rund ist.
Genau, man möchte also die eigentliche Form der Erde beobachten und auch die interne Massenverteilung.
Also würde man sozusagen die Gravitation wegnehmen, dann wäre das irgendwie so ein unförmiges, glibberiges, nubbliges Teil.
Genau.
Und warum muss man das wissen?
Das möchte man aus allgemeinem Interesse an der Erde wissen.
Okay, einfach Grundlagenforschung.
Ja, kann man so sagen.
Aber es sind ja auch noch andere Satelliten unterwegs, die Erdbeobachtung machen, die jetzt nicht unbedingt nur der Grundlagenforschung sind.
Ja, es gibt noch einige Satelliten, die die Erdoberfläche beobachten. Zum Beispiel haben wir Envisat, das ist ein sehr großer, sehr teurer und sehr schicker Satellit, der die Umwelt im Allgemeinen beobachtet. Der beobachtet die Zusammensetzung der Atmosphäre. Der guckt nach, was in der Atmosphäre so rumfliegt, welche anderen Gase da noch sind, wie die Kohlendioxidkonzentrationen sind, was die Ozonschicht so macht. Und der beobachtet die Meeresoberflächen. Der beobachtet irgendwelche Verschmutzungen auf den Meeren. Der beobachtet die Kreuselung der Meeresoberfläche durch Winde. Das ist ein richtig dickes Teil.
Warum ist der so groß? Ich habe gehört, er ist so wie zwei VW-Busse.
Der ist groß wie ein Bus. Er hat eine Solarzelle, die so groß ist wie ein Tennisplatz. Ein richtig dickes Teil. Der stammt aus einer vergangenen Phase der Raumfahrt. Da war man auch dazu geneigt, alle Eier in einen Korb zu legen. Wie man so sagt. Man hat sich also getraut, sehr viel Geld in sehr viele Instrumente zu investieren, die man auf einen Satelliten gepackt hat. Da hat man heute ein bisschen Bammel vor. Heutzutage, zehn Jahre nach dem Start von Envisat, tendiert man mehr dazu, mehrere kleine Satelliten zu bauen. Und wenn einer davon vorunglückt, dumm gelaufen, dann macht man den nächsten. Aber wenn Envisat vorunglückt wäre, hätte die ESA echt ein Problem gehabt.
Hat aber geklappt.
Hat aber geklappt, ja. Und der funktioniert wirklich gut und liefert spektakuläre Wissenschaftsergebnisse.
Ich meine, bei der ESA klappt ja auch nicht alles. Also, ich meine, die aktuelle Entregerrakete ist ja die Ariane 5. Das ist ja auch ein relativ dickes Teil im Vergleich, glaube ich, zu der Ursprungs-Ariane oder der vorherigen Ariane-Generation.
Ja, die ist die schwerste Rakete, die kommerziell zum Satellitenstart eingesetzt wird im Moment. Und die ist in der Hinsicht erfolgreich. Die wurde von der ESA entwickelt, wird aber jetzt von einer Privatfirma vermarktet, die auch mit der ESA zusammenhängt. Und damit wird richtig die Kohle verdient. Die Europäer sind damit Weltmarktführer bei Satellitenstarts.
Weil die so effizient und zuverlässig ist?
Die ist sehr zuverlässig und präzise. Das heißt, dass die die Satelliten mit sehr großer Genauigkeit in die gewünschte Umlaufbahn bringen.
Das heißt, man muss danach nicht so viel Sprit vergeuden, um sie in die richtige Stelle zu verschieben?
Das ist genau der Grund. Durch diese Präzision sparen die Satellitenbetreiber Sprit für Korrekturmanöver und das ist bares Geld.
Das übersetzt sich dann in Laufzeit, nehme ich an.
Genau.
Aber die erste Ariane ist ja in die Luft geflogen, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Genau, ja. Da war ein Softwarefehler in Zeile 864, der dafür gesäuchtet, dass die Steuerung der Rakete auf ihrem Pfad nicht richtig funktioniert hat.
Was war der Fehler?
Der Fehler war, dass man per Copy und Paste irgendwelche Programmzeilen aus dem Steuerprogramm der vorherigen Raketengeneration der Ariane 4 übernommen hat und dass man die nicht richtig angepasst hat.
Dazu sollten wir vielleicht gleich noch mal kommen, aber bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei den Missionen, die die ESA hat. Also es gibt glaube ich noch so einen anderen Satelliten wie den Envisant, der auch auf der gleichen Umlaufbahn hinterherfliegt.
Er ist zwei, er ist eins, der tut es nicht mehr. Er ist zwei, ist ähnlich aufgebaut wie Envisant in der ähnlichen Zusatzzielsetzung, aber technisch deutlich ein paar Jahre zurück.
Er ist schon viel älter. Das war das 1995 und der andere ist 2002 gestartet worden. Ich habe gerade eine Erinnerung, weil ich vorhin in diesem schönen Kontrollzentrum war, mit diesen schicken Holzpanelen, da wurden immer die Starts zelebriert werden. Da sind dann schöne Tafeln, wo die ganzen Starts aufgeführt sind. Ist es das schon, das ist das, was um die Erde kreist?
Es gibt zum Beispiel SMOSS, der jetzt demnächst gestartet wird, in der zweiten Jahreshälfte. Das ist ein Satellit, der den Wasserkreislauf beobachtet. Der beobachtet also die Verteilung des Wassers in der Erdatmosphäre und die Feuchtigkeit des Bodens und all solche Sachen, die dazu beitragen, dass man wirklich die Wasserkreisläufe auf der Erde besser versteht.
Das heißt, Umweltbeobachtung scheint jetzt auch wirklich ein großes Ding zu sein?
Ja, in dem Zusammenhang muss man auch mal Quay-Osat erwähnen. Das ist ein Satellit, der mit einer Radartechnik die Dicke der Polkappen beobachtet. Und das ist natürlich ein Thema, das im Zusammenhang mit der Klimaerwärmung ziemlich aktuell ist. Und das ist überhaupt noch gar nicht verstanden. Zum Beispiel glaubt man an einigen Stellen der Polkappen, eine Massenzunahme zu beobachten. Das möchte man verstehen, was da vor sich geht.
Auf Basis der Messung jetzt bei dem Satelliten?
Genau.
Wie genau kann der das messen?
Der kann das zentimeterweise messen.
Über die gesamte Fläche der Pole?
Genau, ja.
Beide Pole, also der kreist sozusagen beide Pole rüber und misst sozusagen sowohl Nordpol als auch Südpol?
Genau.
Haben wir jetzt schon die wichtigen Missionen über der Erde zusammengefasst? Also wie viele Missionen gibt es überhaupt parallel, die jetzt sozusagen at this moment laufen und von hier überwacht werden?
Weiß nicht auswendig. Also es gibt diese…
Größenordnung?
Zehn. Zehn. So was in der Größenordnung. Fünfzehn.
Also keine hundert.
Nee, nee, nee. Keine hundert.
Zweistellige Zahl. Haben wir jetzt die Relevanten, vielleicht gehen wir mal weg von der Erdbeobachtung, seit wir haben jetzt irgendwas Nee, das ist was. Ganz wichtiges. Was findet sozusagen mit der Erde im Rücken statt? Was richtet sich auf andere Planeten oder ins Weltall?
Ja, wir haben da einige Emissionen unterwegs zu anderen Planeten, zum Beispiel die Sonde Venus Express, die die Venus umkreist, Mars Express und den Mars, die sind beide da. Die sind beide da, produzieren.
Die fotografieren vor allem die Oberfläche.
Ja, aber die haben maßgestaltete Sensoren, die da alles mögliche beobachten können. Zum Beispiel hat Mars Express auch spezielle Radarantennen an Bord, die die Struktur des Mars-Bodens tief unter der Oberfläche beobachten können. Diese Radar-Stallen dringen einigermaßen tief in die Mars-Oberfläche ein, können auch feststellen, ob da Wasser ist. Wir wissen jetzt, ja, da ist Wasser und Wasser ist.
Wer hat das eigentlich festgestellt? Was war der eigentliche Durchbruch, an dem jetzt unwiderlegbar festgestellt wurde, dass es dort Eis gibt?
Also das waren erstmal die Messungen von Mars Express sicherlich auch, aber auch die Amerikaner haben da fleißig dran gearbeitet. Die haben ja einige oder zwei sehr tüchtige Roboter auf der Oberfläche, diese Mars Exploration Rovers Spirit und Opportunity. Und die Messungen sind alle ganz konsistent, also sowohl auf der Oberfläche als auch aus dem Mars Orbit kann man beobachten, dass da früher mal an der Oberfläche Wasser gegeben hat und dass es unterhalb der Mars Oberfläche noch Wasser gibt, was Eis gibt.
Und ist schon Eis selbst gefunden worden?
Ja, hat man jetzt auch gefunden. Also an dem Mars Polen steht auch eine Landessonde, die jetzt nicht mehr funktioniert, aber die hat nach der Landung eine ganze Zeit lang ganz gut funktioniert.
Von den Amerikanern? Phoenix.
Und die hat dann direkt und in situ Wasser alles beobachtet.
Und wo wir jetzt auch gerade die Sache mit der explodierenden Arane 5 hatten, war es nicht so, dass die Mars Express auch diese eine gescheiterte Mission der Amerikaner wiedergefunden hat, wie hieß es noch gleich? Der eine, der irgendwie aufgeschlagen ist auf der Mars-Oberfläche?
Nee, das war eigentlich umgekehrt. Also die Mars Express hatte auch eine Landessonde an Wort.
Ah, genau.
Beagle 2. Ah ja, richtig.
Beagle 2 war von Mars Express. Und die kam nicht an.
Und die ist irgendwie auf der Mars-Oberfläche zerschellt und man weiß nicht mehr, was da vorgefallen ist. Sehr ärgerlich. Man hat durch die Konzeption der ganzen Sonde erst mal dieses katastrophale Versagen gegeben. Und man hat leider auch aus Geldspargründen verzichtet, während des Eintritts in die Marsatmosphäre und während der Landung da Funksignale loszuschicken. Und jetzt hat man nicht mal Gelegenheit gehabt, da was draus zu lernen, was man da falsch gemacht hat.
Ist einfach nur weg. Weiß den Amerikanern nicht auch mal was abgegangen?
Ja, denen ist da einiges schiefgegangen. Also der Mars ist ein Friedhof für gescheiterte Missionen. Da hat es viele katastrophale Fehlfunktionen gegeben. Also die Amerikaner haben auch eine Mission oder auch geschickt zur Beobachtung des Marsklimas. Und der ist durch einen Navigationsfehler in der Marsatmosphäre verbrannt. Das sollte eigentlich irgendwie umlaufbar sein, aber durch einen Fehler ist er halt nicht angelangt.
War das das mit der Inschuld der Zentimeterumrechnung?
Da hängt das mit zusammen, ja.
Wie verhindert man das? Also so ein Fehler, so weit ich weiß, es gibt ja eigentlich kaum einen Technologiebereich, wo so vorsichtig gearbeitet wird wie in der Raumfahrt.
Da gibt es gar keine Alternative. Das ist extrem teuer so zu machen. Man muss da alles durch simulieren und alles ausprobieren und dann nochmal durchchecken. Aber es gibt da wirklich keine Alternative, denn normalerweise hat man keine Möglichkeit, mehr nach dem Statter einzugreifen und mit dem Schraubenzieher hoch zu fliegen, das in Ordnung zu bringen.
Ja, aber wie wird dieser Fehler, der die Ariane 5 zur Explosion gebracht hat, also ein Copy-Paste-Fehler, das ist ja nun wirklich eine dumme Sache. Was werden da für Maßnahmen ergriffen, um da eine Qualitätssicherung vorzunehmen?
Alles wird gründlichst getestet und ausprobiert und nochmal getestet. Aber diesen einen logischen Zweig, den hat man nicht richtig berücksichtigt offenbar.
Also war der Test falsch oder ist es nicht getestet worden?
Ja, es ist getestet worden, aber man hat da beim Test nicht an diese Fehlermöglichkeit gedacht. Das ist die Kunst bei den Tests. Man muss sich wirklich an den Schädel kratzen und sich überlegen, was könnte hier schiefgehen? Was für Situationen könnte diese Software konfrontiert werden?
Ein fehlendes Semikolon und schon wird es echt teuer.
Genau.
Das muss wirklich finster frustrierend sein. Da leidet man mit. Bleiben wir noch mal bei den Missionen. Da gibt es diesen Kometenjäger. Da gab es ja auch schon mal einen.
Ja, die Europäer waren da eigentlich früher schon seit einiger Zeit. Die haben in den 80er Jahren die Giotto-Sonde zum Kometenhelle geschickt.
Die haben uns ja regelmäßig beehrt.
Ja, der kommt alle 76 Jahre. Wer ihn damals nicht gesehen hat, wer heute lebt und ihn damals nicht gesehen hat, hat wahrscheinlich keine zweite Gelegenheit mehr. Das ist so ein typisches Once-in-a-lifetime-Erlebnis. Wann war das? Das war 86.
86? Okay, meine Chance ist dahin. Es sei denn, die Medizin hat noch entscheidende Fortschritte zu vermelden.
Ja, ernähr dich gesund, treibe Sport, dann wird das was.
Okay.
Ja, ich habe meine Chance genutzt. Ich habe ihn selber gesehen, finde ich gut.
So richtig durchs Teleskop, oder wie?
Durchs Teleskop mit bloßem Auge bei mehreren Gelegenheiten.
Und wie sah der aus?
Als ein unspektakuläres, nebeliges Wölkchen am Himmel.
Ja, aber immerhin, der hellische Komet. Ja, aber wie hieß er? Jotto. Was hat der gemacht?
Der ist in großer Nähe an dem Kern des Kometen vorbeigeflogen. Den Kometen kann man sich als schmutzigen Schneeball vorstellen. Das ist eine Mischung aus verschiedenen Eisorten, Wasser, Kohlendioxid, da sind ein paar organische Bestandteile drin. Organische, chemische Elemente, Substanzen, da ist ein bisschen Staub drin. Und wenn der weit von der Sonne weg ist, ist das erstmal wirklich ein ziemlich stabiles Gebilde, Eisklotz mit was drin. Wenn der aber in die Nähe der Sonne kommt, suplimieren diese Eisbestandteile, die da drin sind. Das heißt, die bilden gar keine flüssige Phase aus, sondern verdampfen gleich und bilden dann eine ziemlich bisweilen spektakulär aussehende Wolke um den Satelliten herum, die dann auch vom Sonnenwind und von der Sonnenstrahlung vom Kometen weggeblasen werden.
Das ist dieser biblische Kometenschweif, den man immer anbietet.
Genau.
Und dann ist dieser Satellit hinter diesem Kometen geflohen?
Nee, ist mit großer Geschwindigkeit.
Dann vorbeigeflogen?
Aber in großer Nähe auch. Dann vorbeigeflogen und hat so richtig in diese Wolke reingestürt.
Was ist eine große Nähe in der Planetarium? Ein paar hundert Kilometer. Wie groß muss man sich den vorstellen? Was hat der für einen Durchmesser?
Ein paar Dutzend Kilometer, 30 oder 40 vielleicht.
30 oder 40. Das heißt, das Ding ist irgendwie so groß wie Berlin.
Ja, so kann man sich das jetzt vorstellen.
Berlin fliegt also jetzt durchs Weltall und hat so einen Dreckschweif von Stichmikartygängern und so weiter, die da permanent ausgestoßen werden. Was findet man da drin?
Man findet da einen tollen Mix von chemischen Substanzen. Und die findet man unheimlich spannend, denn Kometen, so glaube ich von heute, sind bei der Entstehung des Sonnensystems eigentlich übrig geblieben aus der Urmaterie. Man hat es ja so vorzustellen, dass es zunächst mal eine große Staub- und Dreckswolke gab, aus der sich dann durch Gravitationswirkungen im Wesentlichen wie Planeten gebildet haben. Das heißt, die Sonne ist entstanden in der Mitte dieser Staubwolke und drumherum auch die Planeten, die Erde natürlich auch in diesem Prozess. Aber da ist noch Baumaterial aus dieser Wolke übrig geblieben, die nicht zu irgendwelchen Planeten verbacken wurde. Und dieses Material, das sind die Kometen im Wesentlichen.
Das sind also gescheiterte Planeten eigentlich.
Ja, genau, so kann man sagen. Und wenn man diese Materie kennt und wenn man versteht, was das ist, dann hat man eine Menge über die Entstehung des Sonnensystems und der Erde auch gelernt.
Das heißt, man blickt im Prinzip sozusagen in so einem Zustand eines Urplaneten, der nie so richtig einer geworden ist. Man kann davon aussehen.
Ja, genau. Also man möchte wirklich wissen, was dazu geführt hat, dass...
Aber diese neue Mission, die hat jetzt irgendwie auch noch so einen besonderen sportlichen Anreiz.
Ja, die ist deutlich aufwendiger. Also das nächste Mal von der Zielsetzung. Also Rosetta möchte nicht mit hoher Geschwindigkeit dran vorbeifliegen, sondern Rosetta möchte wirklich einige Zeit neben dem Kometen wirklich entlangfliegen und beobachten, was passiert, wenn der Komet tatsächlich in der Nähe der Sonne kommt. Er möchte beobachten, wie das Material da abdampft, was da freigesetzt wird.
Wie lange soll er ihn verfolgen?
Einige Monate zumindest, ich weiß nicht genau.
Monate? Das heißt, man fliegt hin. Welcher Komet ist das dann?
Das ist der Komet Shuryumov-Gerasimenko. Also die Sonde ist 2005, glaube ich, 2004 gestartet worden. Und die wird erst im Jahre 2014 da ankommen. Wenige Monate vor der übernächsten Fußball-WM. Ja, das kann man sich doch merken.
Ja, da hat man es auch mit fliegenden Bällen zu tun. Und wo ist das dann?
Weit draußen im Sonnensystem, also zwischen Mars und der Jupiter-Bahn. Oder ja auch noch außerhalb der Jupiter-Bahn, glaube ich.
Also richtig weit weg. Oha, da hat man ja schon so richtig mit so einer Signallatenz zu kämpfen.
Auf jeden Fall, ja.
Ist das da nicht irgendwie sehr kritisch? Müssen wir da sehr kurzfristig reagieren oder ist das im Wesentlichen alles so mit vorberechnetem Bahn?
Nein, das geht nur mit vorberechneten Kommandos, die dann in den Speicher geschrieben werden, mit einer Zeitmarke. Und wenn die Zeit gekommen ist, dann wird dieses Kommando ausgeführt.
Das heißt, der hat jetzt im Prinzip sein Programm schon am Start und man muss...
Nein, das nicht. Die Kommandos werden regelmäßig da hochgeschickt, aber nicht für die ganze Mission.
Also immer nur das nächste Programm für die nächsten Tage, Wochen, Monate?
Genau, oder für die nächsten Stunden oder so.
Wie lange braucht das Signal von hier bis da?
Das ist unterschiedlich. Das hängt von der relativen Entfernung ab. Es schwankt deutlich über die Missionsdauer. Aber so halbe Stunde, Stunde ist typisch.
Halbe Stunde, Stunde. Das ist ja schon signifikant in der Hochzeit. Das Licht braucht schon eine halbe Stunde. Das ist ganz schön weit weg. Und dann schwenkt er halt irgendwie... Also der fängt dann einfach einer, kommt so vorbei, und dann hängt er sich quasi hinter in die Heer.
Durch einige Bahnmanöver wird er in die gleiche Umlaufbahn gebracht. Und dazu ist er natürlich erst mal gestartet worden, relativ normal, und dann in eine Umlaufbahn gebracht worden, die zunächst mal relativ nah an der Erde mit der Erdbahn noch übereinstimmte. Aber dann ist er mal nah an der Erde vorbeigeflogen, hat der Erde dabei ein bisschen kinetische Energie geklaut und ist dadurch schneller geworden durch einen nahen Vorbeiflug.
Und wir haben das hier gemerkt, dadurch, dass eine Sekunde irgendwie auf einmal nicht ganz so lang war.
Nee, also die Erde ist dadurch ein bisschen langsamer geworden, ist doch klar, weil Energie kann man nicht aus nichts erzeugen. Also ein bisschen kinetische Energie ist von der Erde auf die Sonde um.
Also aber der Tag hat dann sozusagen länger gedauert.
Die Erde ist ein bisschen langsamer geworden auf ihrer Umlaufzeit.
Die Umlaufzeit, die Rotation hat das nicht beeinflusst.
Nee, ich denke nicht, nee.
Okay, gut, also das Jahr ist länger geworden, aber der Tag bleibt gleich.
Genau.
Und gut, das heißt...
Der Trick ist, das Wiese bei der Raumfahrtmechanik ist alles kontraintuitiv. Das Jahr ist etwas kürzer geworden. Denn wenn der Planet ein bisschen langsamer wird, wird die Umlaufbahn da verändert. Auch die Geschwindigkeit wird größer. Das gemeint... Also die Erde hat eigentlich Bahnenergie verloren, muss man korrekt sagen.
Das heißt, diese ganzen Satelliten, die rauben uns eigentlich die Zeit.
Das wird sich vielleicht diskutieren.
Ja, hier auf jeden Fall. Aber wenn man so direkt davor steht, muss man sagen, man hat ja immer so Raumschiffe und so weiter. Die sehen ja immer alle so tonschuhförmig gelackt und so weiter aus. Aber wenn man sich mal so einen Satelliten anguckt, dann sieht das immer so ein bisschen aus, als wäre da eigentlich noch gar nicht fertig. Die Dinger sehen ja immer so richtig zusammen. Da fehlt dann irgendwie noch so, da fehlt noch irgendwas. Aber tatsächlich sind sie ja irgendwie so.
Ja, diese werden extrem leicht gebaut. Und die müssen wärmisoliert werden, um Einstrahlung durch die Sonne zu verhindern, und zu verhindern, dass auf der anderen Seite zu viel abgestrahlt wird. Und dazu müssen die erstmal mit so einer, typischerweise mit so einer locker besetzten Folie da eingespannt werden. Und dadurch sehen die manchmal billig aus. Sind sie aber nicht.
Nee, sie sind bestimmt scheiße teuer. Und das ist halt im Wesentlichen ist das einfach so ein großer, dunkler Würfel, der dann einfach jetzt diesen Kometen verfolgt. Und dann ist er ein paar Monate mit ihm auf Reisen.
Ja genau, der hat auch noch große Solarzellen.
Aber soll er nicht irgendwie auch noch drauf gelandet werden?
Genau, an dieser Raumsonde ist noch eine Landesonde angeflanscht. Die ist so groß wie ein Kühlschrank etwa. Hat auch drei Landebeine.
Und die landet dann auf Berlin?
Genau, oder auf Schorium, auf Gerasimenko oder sonst wo.
Ja, ich habe jetzt nur die kurzen Namen. Die anderen habe ich mir nicht gemerkt. Ja, vielleicht noch so, was glaube ich auch ein sehr wichtiges Projekt ist, abgesehen davon, dass wahrscheinlich alle Projekte hier relativ wichtig sind. Aber es ist ja jetzt auch ein, nein gleich zwei, sagt man Teleskope, Umfahrtbeobachtungsgeräte auf einmal gestartet worden. Also eine Ariane hat vielleicht zwei Satelliten nach oben. Also nicht Satelliten, sondern, wie sagt man Satelliten dazu? Nein, man sagt nicht Satelliten, weil die im Kreis sind.
Das ist ein bisschen umstritten, wie ob man die als Satelliten bezeichnet. Eigentlich bezeichnet man Raumflugkörper, die die Erde umkreisen als Satelliten. Und alles, was da im All rumfliegt zu den Planeten, das bezeichnet man als Raumsonden. Da ist aber so ein Zwischenbereich, denn die fliegen zu dem sogenannten Lagrange-Spunkt 2.
Was ist das?
Das ist ein Parkplatz für Raumfahrzeuge außerhalb der Erdbahn. Der liegt genau auf der Verbindungsgrade zwischen Erde und Sonne, aber auf dieser Gerade außerhalb der Erdbahn. 1,5 Millionen Kilometer außerhalb der Erdbahn. Und eigentlich dürfte man da...
Also sozusagen zwischen Erde und Mars?
Genau, ja. Aber noch relativ nah bei der Erde. Der Abstand Erde-Sonne ist etwa 148 Millionen Kilometer, aber 1,5 Millionen Kilometer in die andere Richtung nach außen findet man diesen Lagrange-Spunkt.
Und was ist da so attraktiv an dem Punkt?
Der ist extrem günstig für solche Beobachtungssatelliten. Stell dir vor, wenn das Hubble Space Teleskop zum Beispiel im Kreis die Erde, aber wenn man mit dem Hubble Space Teleskop einen bestimmten Stern beobachten möchte, dann geht das typischerweise nur für 40 oder 50 Minuten, weil dann in die Richtung, in die der Satellitgut guckt, die Erde wieder dazwischen kommt.
Die Erde verdeckt sozusagen die Sicht?
Genau. Und des Weiteren darf das Hubble Space Teleskop natürlich auch nicht zur Sonne gucken, ist doch klar, weil wenn die Sonnenwärme in das Teleskop dringen würde, würde das sofort die Sensoren verbratzen durch die große Wärme.
Das heißt, es ist schon sinnvoll, dass man die Erde sozusagen, dass man im Schatten ist, dass die Erde die Sonne verdeckt?
Ne, nicht ganz. Also die Erde soll die Sonne nicht verdecken, weil man ja auch die Sonnenstrahlung braucht, um die Solarzellen zu betreiben. Aber man möchte halt möglichst den ganzen Himmel zur Beobachtung auch zugänglich haben. Deswegen ist dieser L2-Punkt so genial, denn von dem aus gesehen erscheint die Erde, die ja potenziell auch blockt, und die Sonne in die genau gleiche Richtung. Deswegen hat man praktisch den ganzen Rest des Himmels zur Beobachtung.
Die schauen in die gleiche Richtung?
Also von dem Lagrange-Punkt aus gesehen erscheinen die Erde und die Sonne in der gleichen Richtung. Also wieder auf der...
Aber es verdeckt nicht im eigentlichen Sinne. Sie sind so schon nebeneinander.
Sie sind zwar nah beieinander, aber verdecken sich nicht wirklich gegenseitig. Also die Sonne verdeckt die Erde nicht, weil man nicht auf diesem wirklich idealen Lagrange-Punkt ist, sondern diesen Lagrange-Punkt umkreist.
Das heißt, würde man sich jetzt wirklich in dem Lagrange-Punkt befinden, dann ist das wirklich die direkte Flucht von Erde und Sonne, und man würde die Sonne nicht sehen.
Von da aus wäre die Sonne etwas größer als die Erde, deswegen würde dann noch ein kleiner...... Genau, ja.
Das wäre auch sehr schick aus, oder?
Ja, das wäre sehr schick, aber das ist nicht gut, weil man da nicht genügt Energie für die...
Das heißt, man ist so ein bisschen weiter nach links gerutscht? Was ist dann noch der Vorteil? Dann kann man doch auch irgendwo sein.
Nee, aber der Vorteil ist, dass dann Sonne und Erde immer noch etwa in die gleiche Richtung stehen. Und der ganze Rest ist sozusagen für die Beobachtung zugänglich.
Ach so, weil das wirklich die einzigen Punkte sind, die einen jetzt nicht interessiert. Man will nicht in die Sonne gucken. Und man will auch nicht auf die Erde gucken, weil die kennt man schon.
Genau.
Und dann sozusagen alles andere ist dann wirklich frei. Ah, jetzt habe ich es begriffen.
Und das ist echt genial für die Beobachtung. Das war bis vor wenigen Jahren...
Aber warum dann genau 1,5 Millionen? Ich meine, man könnte ja auch nur eine Million fahren, dann hätte man ja auch die beiden sozusagen, dann wären sie vielleicht sogar gleich groß.
Richtig, aber das funktioniert nicht. Man kann irgendwo anders keinen Satelliten stabil unterbringen. Denn je eigentlich es so, je weiter eine Umlaufbahn von der Sonne weg ist, desto langsamer wird die. Das heißt, normalerweise würde ein Satellit da relativ zur Erde zurückfallen, weil der auf einer etwas langsameren Umlaufbahn ist. Aber durch die Gravitationswirkung der Erde wiederum wird das ausgeglichen und man hat da so einen Punkt, auf dem das wirklich stabil genau ausgeglichen ist.
Das heißt, der Abstand ist so gewählt, dass die Erdanziehungskraft so schwach ist, also noch so stark ist, dass sie einen mitschleppt, ob es oben oder weiter draußen ist?
So kann man sich das vorstellen, ja.
Und man hat trotzdem den Vorteil, dass man irgendwie nicht so viel Himmelsfeld verschwendet und das Teleskop kann dann irgendwie gucken. Und jetzt sind es ja zwei, Herrschel und Planck, die sind vollkommen anders aufgebaut, die schauen sich komplett andere Sachen an, aber die hängen da beide am gleichen Ort rum.
In etwa, ja. Planck hat ein etwas engeres, etwas engere Umlaufbahn um den L2 als Herrschel, aber im Prinzip machen die das ähnlich.
Und Herrschel ist jetzt im Prinzip so eine Art Hubble, richtig? Also der schaut so in, der fotografiert das Weltall.
Genau, ja. Das ist ein sehr maßgeschneidertes, astronomisches Teleskop, maßgeschneidert in der Hinsicht, dass es sich auf kalte Objekte konzentrieren möchte. Kalte und rot verschobene Objekte.
Also Planeten oder was?
Ja, genau. Aber vor allen Dingen auch Objekte, die kaum eine eigene Wärmestrahlung, die nicht sehr warm sind, die typischerweise einige gerade Temperatur über dem absoluten Nullpunkt haben. Kometen zum Beispiel sind solche Objekte, die sind typischerweise sehr kalt. Aber es gibt auch Staubwolke im All, die so kalt sind. Paradoxerweise kann man solche Objekte am besten in der Infrarotstrahlung beobachten. Also eigentlich eine Wärmestrahlung. Und das macht Herschel, das macht Planck. Herschel und Planck werden beide durch verdampftes Helium fortwährend gekühlt auf Temperaturen knapp über dem absoluten Nullpunkt. Und können auch nur bei dieser Temperatur arbeiten. Das heißt, dass die durch das verdampfende und kühlende Helium praktisch auch eine tickende Uhr des Todes haben. Wenn das Helium verdampft ist, ist die Mission zu Ende. Bei Plank wird das ungefähr nach 1,5 bis 2 Jahren der Fall sein. Und bei Herschel soll das über 4 Jahre dauern.
Oh, das ist ja nicht so viel. Das heißt, man hat eigentlich nur eine sehr kurze Phase, wo man die Dinger wirklich nutzen kann. Anders als Hubble, der jetzt schon seit, was weiß ich, 15 Jahren unterwegs ist und jetzt noch ein bisschen durch die Nachbesserung, glaube ich, noch mal ein bisschen Verlängerung kriegt.
Die haben noch ein paar Lebensjahre gekauft.
Und das lohnt sich?
Unbedingt, ja. Es geht nicht anders zu machen. Und man hört sich schon eine Menge...
Was schaut sich den Planck dann an, wenn Herrscher sich irgendwie auf die Kälteobjekte konzentriert?
Planck ist auch wiederum sehr maßgeschneidert. Und Planck soll eine Mikrowellenstrahlung beobachten, die man als nachglühendes Urknalls verstehen kann.
Also ich will jetzt nicht in die komplette Geschichte des Weltalls jetzt eingehen an der Stelle, aber Urknall ist sozusagen die Theorie, die bisher noch nicht ausreichend widerlegt ist, deswegen nimmt man das mal an, so war es.
Kann man so sagen, man könnte aber auch sagen, dass es mittlerweile hieb- und stichfeste Indizien dafür gibt.
Okay, also zumindest, das ist das, wie man sozusagen heute das Weltall sieht. Es gab diesen Urknall, das Universum dehnt sich aus, in einer nicht nachvollziehbaren Geschwindigkeit. Und man kann sozusagen in diese Geschichte des Weltalls zurückschauen, indem man diese Strahlung, diese spezielle Strahlung analysiert, weil sie quasi so ein Nachhall-Effekt ist von diesem Urknall.
Genau, ja.
Hast du das schon mal richtig zusammengefasst?
Das hast du richtig zusammengefasst. Und in dieser Strahlung kann man eigentlich einige Informationen über den Urknall finden. Man kann sich so vorstellen, dass das ganze Universum erst mal undurchsichtig war. In den ersten 380.000 Jahren, da ist das Universum fortschreitend erkälter geworden. Aber bis die ersten 380.000 Jahre war es mit Plasma erfüllt. Das heißt, dass die Elektronen von ihren Atomen getrennt waren. Und zwar ist es undurchsichtig. Aber durch diese fortwährende Ausdehnung ist das Universum immer kälter geworden. Das passiert heute auch noch. Aber plötzlich, nach 380.000 Jahren, war eine kritische Temperatur unterschritten, ab der halt die Atome wieder von den zugehörigen Atomen absorbiert worden sind. Das heißt, dass das Universum zu dem Zeitpunkt schlagartig durchsichtig geworden ist. Die Elektronen wurden von den Atomen absorbiert. Zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist das Universum schlagartig von jetzt auf gleich durchsichtig geworden. Es hat sich praktisch so eine Wolkenbank gebildet. Man kann also außerhalb des klaren, durchsichtigen Universums in die Vergangenheit blicken, auf diese Nebelwand, die da entstanden ist, durch diesen Übergang. Je weiter man wegguckt, desto mehr guckt man in die Vergangenheit. Das heißt, dass man irgendwann auch in die Vergangenheit guckt, in der das Universum noch nicht durchsichtig war. Da hat man dann praktisch um einen herum so eine…
Das heißt, wir sitzen im Prinzip in einer riesigen Glaskugel, wo dann die Arme in der Wichte wandt ist. Da fängt gerade das Universum an.
Genau, ja.
Obwohl das natürlich schon längst vorbei ist.
Man blickt so weit in die Vergangenheit und erreicht dann schließlich bei seinem Blick einen Punkt, der unersichtig ist.
Das heißt, das Universum hat dann am Ende auch noch irgendeine spezielle Farbe.
Ja, genau, kann man so sagen.
Dass man versucht, Plank jetzt herauszufinden, welche Farbe das hat.
Kann man so sehen, ja. Das mit der Farbe ist so eine Sache. Als dieser Übergang stattfand, war die Farbe des Universums so glühend, fast so wie die Sonne jetzt ist. So kann man sich das fast vorstellen. Aber diese Farbe hat sich verändert. Weil sich das Universum immer weiter ausdehnt, wird diese Farbe immer roter. Und durch diese fortschreitende Ausdehnung ist aus diesem glühenden, sonnenfarbigen Glühen eine Mikrowellenstrahlung geworden.
Weil es sie einfach so gestreckt hat?
Genau. Und deswegen ist das heutzutage eine Mikrowellenstrahlung. Und die kann nur von extrem kalten Sensoren beobachtet werden.
Das ist auch wieder dieser Frequenzdehnungseffekt, den man so von vorbeifahrenen Autos...
Ja, es ist ein analoger Effekt, könnte man sagen. Ein bisschen vorsichtig damit, aber... Na klar. Das macht Planck. Planck möchte gerne sämtliche Information, die in dieser Mikrowellenstrahlung steckt, extrahieren und dadurch feststellen, wie unser Universum gestrickt ist. Zum Beispiel möchte man gerne wissen, ob unser Universum flach ist. Was ist flach, wenn man immer über das Universum spricht? Flach wäre das Universum, wenn man zwei parallele Strahlen losschickt. Wenn die immer parallel bleiben, dann ist das Universum flach. Es ist keineswegs sichergestellt, dass das so ist. Bis vor kurzem dachte man, das Universum sei gekrömmt. Das würde bedeuten, dass die parallele Strahlen sich irgendwann doch schneiden. Das kann man sich nicht wirklich vorstellen, weil man sich solche Konzepte nicht vorstellen kann. Das menschliche Gehirn ist dafür nicht gestrickt.
Mathematiker beweisen einem ja alles.
Aber man redet nicht schlecht über Mathematiker. Die haben oft recht und kommen mit verblüffenden Sachen raus.
Aber es ist nicht krumm.
Es sieht nicht so aus. Man hat mittlerweile zwei Vorgängersonden von Planck gehabt. Der erste hieß Coby. Der flog Anfang der 90er Jahre. Und dann gab es WMAP, der flog 2001 oder so. Die haben schon mal ein bisschen an der mikrowellen Hintergrundstrahlung geschnuppert. Und die Messungen von WMAP legen nahe, dass das Universum flach ist.
Jetzt sind wir schon sehr weit gekommen.
Weiter geht es eigentlich gar nicht.
Funktioniert Planck eigentlich schon?
Planck funktioniert gut. Man muss aber noch ein bisschen weiter warten, bis er noch weiter abkühlt.
Also sozusagen im Betrieb, aber es ist jetzt noch nicht so weit, dass man schon...
Der muss noch ein bisschen weiter abkühlen. Der ist noch nicht ganz auf Betriebstemperatur.
Da muss man ein bisschen Helium verdampfen. Aber Herrschel hat jetzt gerade sein erstes Licht gesehen.
Ja, wir sind gerade so was von aktuell hier. Am letzten Sonntag wurde der Deckel, die Instrumente geöffnet. Und kurz danach wurden auch die ersten Aufnahmen gemacht. Und die waren spektakulär. Gut, die kann man sich auf www.esa.int anschauen. Ab seit heute Mittag.
Was wurde da fotografiert?
Da wurde eine Spiralgalaxie fotografiert, die man als Amateursterngucker eigentlich gut kennt. Die nennt sich M1-50, befindet sich im Sternbild Jagdhunde am Nordhimmel, nicht weit weg vom großen Wagen. Und die ist ästhetisch besonders ansprechend.
Das ist so ein Klassiker sozusagen.
Genau, ja. War auch gerade beobachtungstechnisch sehr günstig gelegen. Und deswegen wurde die ausgenommen. Weil es auch richtig was hermacht für die Presse.
Und das ist jetzt sozusagen ein Bild, wie es das noch nie gab? Also wodurch besticht das Bild durch irgendetwas, außer dass es jetzt sozusagen das erste ist?
Ja, durch die große Detailfülle. Ich hatte ja schon gesagt, dass Herrscher im Wesentlichen, nicht im Wesentlichen, ausschließlich im Infraroten beobachtet. Und da tritt ein Effekt sehr ungünstig auf, nämlich dass mit zunehmender Beobachtungswellenlänge die Auflösung zurückgeht. Das heißt, wenn man ein Objekt im violetten Licht sehr scharf sehen kann, sieht man das im roten Licht weniger scharf durch diese zunehmende Wellenlänge. Und dieser Effekt nimmt immer weiter zu, je weiter man das Infrarote geht. Und deswegen braucht man bei so Infrarotenwellenlängen schon ein sehr großes Teleskop, um eine optische Auflösung zu kriegen, wie man auf der Erde bei sichtbaren Licht mit einem kleinen Amateur-Teleskop hat.
Und vor allem muss man schön weit weg sein von der Erde und ihrer bösen Atmosphäre, weil das ja alles irgendwie verzerrt und verdeckt und abschwächt.
Also die meisten Bestandteile der Infrarotstrahlung kommen nicht durch. Teilweise ist die Atmosphäre aber durchlässig für Wärmestrahlung. Die Wärmestrahlung, die uns angenehm im Bauch wärmt, jetzt im Sommer im Park, das ist auch Wärmestrahlung, die durch ein zufällig vorhandenes Spektralfenster durch die Erdatmosphäre dringt. Aber die Wellenlänge, in denen diese interessanten Astronomischen Objekte leuchten, die gehen da nicht durch und deswegen kann man die nur eigentlich aus dem All beobachten. Oder zumindest aus extrem hoch fliegenden Balance.
Zum Abschluss wollte ich noch mal erinnern an so zwei Projekte, die schon lange her sind, die mich persönlich immer sehr fasziniert haben, nämlich die Voyager-Mission. Das sind die Voyager 1 und 2, die ja, ich weiß nicht, sowas wird derzeit, glaube ich, gar nicht mehr gemacht, oder? Dass man einfach mal irgendwas ganz weit wegschickt.
Doch, doch, doch, das wird schon gemacht. Also zur Zeit ist noch eine Sonne zum Pluto unterwegs. Mit ähnlicher Zielsetzung wie beim Voyager. Die machen dann schnell einen Vorbeiflug und gucken dann kurz und nachhaltig zum Pluto.
Aber Voyager 1 ist, glaube ich, das von der Erde am weitesten entfernte Objekt, was...
Ich glaube, Voyager 2 ist es.
2 ist weit weg. Die haben bereits das Sonnensystem, also unser Sonnensystem. Das ist das Sonnensystem. Verlassen?
Also Voyager 1 und 2 sind beide am Jupiter und am Saturn vorbeigeflogen und Voyager 2 ist dann auch weiter zum Uranus und Neptun geflogen und haben da also das Wissen der Menschheit dramatisch erweitert.
Das sind die einzigen Bilder, die es sozusagen gibt von diesen Planeten oder?
Ja, mittlerweile hat man von Jupiter und Saturn noch Fotos von anderen Sonden, die auch mittlerweile deutlich besser sind, aber von Uranus und Neptun gibt es sonst keine Aufnahmen.
Nur von Voyager?
Nur von Voyager.
Und ist da noch irgendwas unterwegs? Interessiert das noch jemanden? Ach so, wenn da einer zum Pluto unterwegs ist, wo ist der jetzt gerade?
Der ist im Gegensatz der Saturnbein schon.
Ah ja, das heißt Neptun und Uranus steht da sozusagen als nächstes an?
Nee, die stehen dann ganz woanders, die liegen nicht auf dem Weg.
Ach so, das heißt nächste Haltestelle ist Pluto?
Genau.
Obwohl das gar kein Planet mehr ist?
Ja, ich finde das gemein.
Der arme Pluto.
Ja, ich finde das auch nicht gut, so etwas, so einen gestandenen Planeten da zu degradieren. Das macht man nicht, finde ich. Das ist auch in der Astronomenszene sehr umstritten. Man kann da trefflich und lange diskutieren, ob das gut war.
Ich finde das nicht gut.
Da steckt auch eine Menge Kultur drin in so einer...
Das war schon immer so.
Ja, und das ist ein verdammt gutes Argument, finde ich.
Und das bei einer Wissenschaft, die doch so jung ist. Na ja, mal sehen. Vielleicht ein Thema für eine künftige Sendung von Chaos Radio Express. Ich will an dieser Stelle mal ein Ende setzen, denn hier soll es jetzt erstmal gehen um Raumfahrt und die Sendung ist, wie so viele, auch ein kleines Experiment gewesen. Ich bin häufig auf diesen Themenbereich überhaupt erst mal hingewiesen worden. Ich sollte doch mal was zu Raumfahrt machen bzw. überhaupt alles, was sozusagen mit Jenseits der Erde zu tun hat. Wusste lange nicht so richtig, wie ich das jetzt aufnehme. Das war jetzt eigentlich so ein bisschen mal so der erste Ansatz. Deswegen hier auch so dieser grobe Überflug über, was es denn eigentlich alles so gibt, um die Dinge überhaupt erst mal in Kontext zu setzen. Ich bin sehr gespannt auf die Kommentare, was sozusagen sich, wie das jetzt so aufprallt, bei den Hörern. Und würde gerne hören, was, ja, ob das was ist, was man vielleicht noch mal weiter ausbauen sollte. Bin ich auch gerne bereit, mir mal das ein oder andere Thema noch mal genauer anzuschauen, weil man ja schon merkt, man kann hier wirklich in jedem Bereich eigentlich die Themen-Dichte noch mal bediebig weit auffächern. Ja, Rainer, super.
Ja, prima, ich finde das auch nett.
Das war ein tolles Gespräch und ich frage jetzt gar nicht, ob wir irgendwas vergessen haben, weil das ist...
Wir haben tausend Dinge uns gesprochen.
Das ist wirklich die Unendlichkeit im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und ich bedanke mich sehr für die ausführliche Darlegung aller hinterfragten Sachen. Und das war ein schöner Aufenthalt hier. Ich hoffe, ich bin nicht das letzte Mal hier gewesen, wenn wir schon so viel Raumfahrt hier in Bahnenkarten näher haben, dann sollte die auch mal hinterfragt werden. Ja, dann nochmal vielen Dank. Tschüss und bis bald bei Chaos Radio Express.
Auf Wiedersehen!